This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. The year was 1964. The legendary singer, Frank Sinatra, met Mia Farrow, an up-and-coming actress on a soundstage at 20th century Fox. Despite their 30-year age difference, the two began dating and fell madly in love. Frank Sinatra bought Mia Farrow a massive 9-carat pear-shaped diamond ring. He proposed at his home in Palm Springs. The wedding itself was a small civil ceremony, but the celebration was lavish. The groom gifted its bride an expensive double-row diamond bracelet.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。那是1964年。传奇歌手弗兰克·辛纳屈在20世纪福克斯公司的摄影棚里遇到了崭露头角的演员米亚·法罗。尽管两人有30岁的年龄差，他们还是开始约会并坠入爱河。弗兰克·辛纳屈为米亚·法罗买了一枚巨大的9克拉梨形钻戒。他在棕榈泉的家中向她求婚。婚礼本身是一场小型民事仪式，但庆祝活动却极其奢华。新郎送给新娘一条昂贵的双排钻石手链。
Not long after, Mia Farrow was on the set of Rosemary's baby when she was issued divorce papers. Frank Sinatra, didn't want her to work. He was just old-fashioned, Mia Farrow later explained. They divorced just two years after saying, I do. Did the couple not talk before they got married? Did they not discuss their values? How is it they failed to see they were not on the same page on such an important question? In 2014, two economics professors weighed in on the issue. They published a paper titled A Diamond is Forever and other fairy tales. They looked at how much couples spent on their engagement rings and weddings and tracked how long their marriages lasted. They found that the more
不久之后，米亚·法罗在拍摄《罗斯玛丽的婴儿》时收到了离婚协议书。米亚·法罗后来解释说，弗兰克·辛纳屈不想让她工作。他只是思想守旧。他们在说出“我愿意”仅仅两年后就离婚了。这对夫妇在结婚前没有交流过吗？他们没有讨论过彼此的价值观吗？他们怎么会没发现自己在如此重要的问题上意见不合呢？2014年，两位经济学教授对此发表了看法。他们发表了一篇题为《钻石恒久远及其他童话故事》的论文。他们研究了情侣在订婚戒指和婚礼上的花费，并追踪了他们婚姻的持续时间。他们发现，花费越
money couples spend on their weddings or engagement rings, the less likely they were to stay together over the long term. The opposite was also true. Spending less on the wedding and engagement ring predicted a longer marriage. Today, we explore the many ways in which our desire to focus on the beautiful keeps us from attending to the basics. We'll examine how this problem shapes not just individual lives, but organizations and businesses and even public policy. Why great ideas fail and how to keep them from failing?
多钱在婚礼或订婚戒指上的情侣，长期维持婚姻的可能性就越小。反之亦然。在婚礼和订婚戒指上花费较少，预示着婚姻会更长久。今天，我们将探讨我们对追求美好事物的渴望如何阻碍我们关注基本要素的多种方式。我们将审视这个问题不仅如何影响个人生活，还如何影响组织、企业甚至公共政策。为什么伟大的想法会失败，以及如何防止它们失败？
This week on Hidden Brain. There's a saying, big dreams start small. Bold visions are achieved when we have the tenacity and audacity to pursue them, but are great ideas enough to get something off the ground? At Stanford University, Hagi Rau studies this question. He has spent years studying the elements of successful entrepreneurship and innovation. Hagi Rau, welcome to Hidden Brain. A pleasure, Shankar. Thank you for having me.
本周的《Hidden Brain》。有句俗话说，伟大的梦想始于微小。当我们有毅力和勇气去追求大胆的愿景时，它们就能实现，但伟大的想法足以让事情起步吗？在斯坦福大学，哈吉·拉奥研究这个问题。他花了多年时间研究成功创业和创新的要素。哈吉·拉奥，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。很高兴，尚卡尔。谢谢你邀请我。
Hagi, I want to start with an example that in recent years, has become synonymous with the definition of a public relations disaster, the Fire Festival. Let's start at the beginning. In 2016, an American businessman named Billy McFarlane had an app that he was looking to promote. It was called the Fire app, F-Y-R-E. What was this app designed to do? Well, the idea behind the app, Shankar, was to connect artists with clients for performances, appearances, and the like. Part of what they wanted to do was to have a luxury music festival.
哈吉，我想从一个近年来已成为公关灾难代名词的例子开始，即“火人节”（Fyre Festival）。让我们从头说起。2016年，一位名叫比利·麦克法兰的美国商人有一个他想推广的应用程序。它叫“火”应用，拼写为F-Y-R-E。这个应用的设计初衷是什么？嗯，尚卡尔，这个应用背后的想法是为表演、出场等活动连接艺术家和客户。他们想做的事情之一就是举办一场豪华音乐节。
And initially the idea was to sort of promote the app, if you will, for booking musical talent. But then what happened was the festival itself took on a momentum in its of its own and swiftly overshadowed the app. So I understand they began selling tickets and some VIP packages ran to $12,000. What would ticket buyers being promised for that kind of money? Very exotic things, I might add. They were promised accommodation in geodesic domes that were eco-friendly and presumably modern, and celebrity chefs would provide them meals. That was the launch of the app, if you will.
起初，这个想法是为了推广这个预订音乐人才的应用程序。但后来，音乐节本身产生了一种势头，迅速掩盖了应用程序。所以我了解到他们开始卖票，一些VIP套餐高达12,000美元。购票者花这么多钱能得到什么承诺？我得补充说，是非常异国情调的东西。他们被承诺住在环保且大概很现代的测地圆顶帐篷里，还有名厨为他们提供餐点。这就是该应用的发布，如果你愿意这么说的话。
So I understand that this event was going to take place in the Bahamas, and Billy McFarlane had heard rumors that the island on which they were going to host the event was associated with the Colombian drug lord Pablo Escobar. And this becomes part of the marketing, the branding, the hype, right? Completely. You know, the moment you say Escobar, I mean, you know, quickly, you know, you get notoriety, you get kind of visibility. For this one, they released materials saying this festival was being organized on Pablo Escobar's private island.
所以我了解到这个活动将在巴哈马群岛举行，比利·麦克法兰听说他们要举办活动的岛屿与哥伦比亚毒枭巴勃罗·埃斯科巴有关。这成了营销、品牌推广和炒作的一部分，对吧？完全正确。你知道，当你提到埃斯科巴的那一刻，意味着你很快就能获得知名度，获得某种曝光。为此，他们发布了宣传材料，称这个音乐节是在巴勃罗·埃斯科巴的私人岛屿上组织的。
You know, the sad reality was it was. a remote parking lot north of the Sandals Resort. Oh my gosh. Wow. So the language used to describe this festival. It was called an immersive music festival, two transformative weekends. It was supposed to be on the
你知道，可悲的现实是，它只是凉鞋度假村北边的一个偏远停车场。天哪。哇。所以用来描述这个音乐节的语言。它被称为沉浸式音乐节，两个变革性的周末。它本应处于
boundaries of the impossible. I mean, this was really being pitched to the sky. But as the big day started to approach, major musical acts started to pull out. Why were they pulling out, Huggie? Well, they had, if you will, aspirations of what this festival ought to be, but they completely overlooked the details.
不可能的边缘。我的意思是，这真的是在向天空吹嘘。但随着大日子临近，主要的音乐表演开始退出。他们为什么要退出，哈吉？嗯，他们对这个音乐节应该是什么样子有某种愿景，但他们完全忽略了细节。
There wasn't enough dirt underneath the fingernails of people who were responsible for making this happen. So they didn't have expertise, they didn't have experience, you know, they were trying to do something within a period of six to eight weeks that takes about 12 months to accomplish. Billy McFarlane and the other organizers elected to house the guests in tents. The day before the festival was to start, heavy rains lash the island. By then the first flights were already landing in, people were there, and these initial arrivals were brought to, I guess, what can be described as an impromptu beach party that lasted for six hours. Basically, they were plied with alcohol and they were just waiting where people were scrambling to build the site.
负责实现这一切的人没有足够的实干经验。所以他们没有专业知识，没有经验，你知道，他们试图在六到八周内完成通常需要12个月才能完成的事情。比利·麦克法兰和其他组织者选择让客人们住在帐篷里。音乐节开始的前一天，暴雨袭击了该岛。到那时，第一批航班已经降落，人们已经在那里了，这些最初到达的人被带到了我猜可以被描述为一场持续了六小时的即兴海滩派对的地方。基本上，他们被灌了酒，只能在那里等着，而人们正忙着搭建场地。
I mean, that's just horrifying. At some point now, the people need a place to sleep at night. What happens? Were there enough tents for everyone? Not really. I mean, you had scattered disaster relief tents with dirty flows, with soaking wet mattresses and the like. And you can imagine and visualize that late arrivals were. being brought to the festival by school bus, and as soon as they came in, the disarray and the lack of infrastructure was very, very clear to all of the incoming guests. The gourmet food, of course, was nothing more than cheese sandwiches served in foam containers.
我的意思是，那太可怕了。现在，人们总得有个睡觉的地方。发生了什么？帐篷够所有人住吗？并不够。我的意思是，你看到的是散乱的救灾帐篷，地板很脏，床垫湿透了等等。你可以想象并勾勒出画面，迟到的人被校车带到音乐节，他们一进来，混乱和基础设施的缺乏对所有到来的客人来说都非常非常明显。当然，所谓的美食只不过是泡沫盒里装的奶酪三明治。
Yeah, so apparently there were the problems included a lack of medical personnel on site. wasn't running water. People were told that this was a cash-free festival, and so they hadn't brought money to the event, and they couldn't even figure out a way to make alternate arrangements. That's right, you know. Initially, as a matter of fact, I think there were about 500 or so people. They just didn't have enough tents. And, you know, they just stole them from others. So, and the attendees couldn't even go to the nearby Sandals resort. because it was actually peak season. And so, you know, you can imagine people without food, without shelter, without money,
是的，显然问题还包括现场缺乏医疗人员。没有自来水。人们被告知这是一个无现金音乐节，所以他们没带钱去现场，他们甚至想不出办法做其他安排。没错，你知道。事实上，起初我想大约有500人左右。他们只是没有足够的帐篷。而且，你知道，他们只是从别人那里偷。所以，参加者甚至不能去附近的凉鞋度假村，因为那实际上是旺季。所以，你知道，你可以想象人们没有食物，没有住所，没有钱，
you can imagine what kind of social disintegration quickly ensconcours. So eventually, apparently only a small number of local musicians ever played at this festival for a few hours. And, of course, people started to see that things were falling apart. They were scrambling to get home. But even here, it was difficult to get flights back. People were stuck at the airport for hours. So even the evacuation turned out to be something of a disaster. Completely.
你可以想象什么样的社会瓦解会迅速发生。所以最终，显然只有少数当地音乐家在这个音乐节上演奏了几个小时。当然，人们开始看到事情正在分崩离析。他们争先恐后地想回家。但即使在这里，也很难买到回程机票。人们在机场被困了几个小时。所以即使是撤离也变成了一场灾难。完全正确。
First of all, I mean, there was, you know, an onrush of potential passengers to the airport. Even that was really delayed. And so you got people essentially in a trap. What was the aftermath of all of this, Hagi? What happened to the organizers, Billy McFarland and his colleagues? Did they face any penalties for doing this? They certainly did. You know, immediately there was like a $100 million lawsuit in the state of California,
首先，我的意思是，你知道，潜在乘客涌向机场。即使是那样也真的延误了。所以你基本上把人们困在了陷阱里。这一切的后果是什么，哈吉？组织者比利·麦克法兰和他的同事们发生了什么？他们因为这样做面临任何惩罚吗？他们当然面临了。你知道，立即在加利福尼亚州就有一场1亿美元的诉讼，
and they wanted class action status, and they had 150 plaintiffs, and it was for breach of contract, covenant, misrepresentation, all of that. And in the end, McFarlane was sentenced to six years in prison in 2018, and he had to forfeit $26 million. What went wrong with the fire festival? A better question might be, what didn't go wrong? When we come back, how visionaries fail by not taking into account the planning, preparation, and precision that is needed for real success.
他们想要集体诉讼地位，他们有150名原告，涉及违约、契约、虚假陈述等等。最终，麦克法兰在2018年被判处六年监禁，并被没收了2600万美元。火人节出了什么问题？更好的问题可能是，什么没出问题？当我们回来时，我们将探讨梦想家如何因不考虑真正成功所需的规划、准备和精确度而失败。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all have big dreams. Launch a business. Get a degree. Start a family. What does it take to do those things? Passion? Heart? Vision? Sure. But at Stanford University, Hagi Rao says there are other elements that may matter more. When we overlook them, we can fail to do the great things we aspire to do. Hagi, I want to go back to the year 1987. In Pyongyang, North Korea, construction begins on a new hotel. But it's not any old hotel. It's supposed to outdo a South Korean hotel that was, at the time, the tallest hotel in the world? Yes, absolutely. This was the...
你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们都有伟大的梦想。创办一家企业。获得一个学位。组建一个家庭。做这些事情需要什么？激情？真心？愿景？当然。但在斯坦福大学，哈吉·拉奥说还有其他可能更重要的要素。当我们忽视它们时，我们就可能无法实现我们渴望做到的伟大事情。哈吉，我想回到1987年。在朝鲜平壤，一家新酒店开始动工。但它不是普通的酒店。它本应超过当时世界上最高的酒店，一家韩国酒店？是的，绝对是。这就是……
Rue-Gyong Hotel, I think also called the capital of the Willows, I believe, given the older name for Pyongyang, and indeed it was the response to what the South Koreans were doing with the Olympics. So they wanted to build a hotel for a socialist version of the Olympics, the World Festival of Youth, and the idea was to build this massive hotel called the Rue-Gong Hotel in, to me, Shankar, the rivalry between two nations and two leaders and all of that, it really makes me wonder about how leaders can easily be seduced by the edifice complex, as opposed to the edifice complex. And this is a stellar example of the edifice complex.
柳京饭店，我想也被称为“柳京”，考虑到平壤的旧称，它确实是对韩国人举办奥运会所做出的回应。所以他们想为社会主义版本的奥运会——世界青年与学生联欢节——建造一家酒店，想法是建造这家名为柳京饭店的巨大酒店。对我来说，尚卡尔，两个国家和两位领导人之间的竞争，真的让我思考领导人如何容易被“建筑情结”所诱惑，而不是“建筑情结”。这是一个建筑情结的绝佳例子。
So the building was to have three wings, each sloped, at a 75-degree angle that converged into what looked like a pyramid, 3,000 rooms, 1,000 feet tall. It was supposed to be an engineering marvel that would demonstrate that North Korea was superior to South Korea. The only thing was the North Koreans didn't have expertise and experience with a variety of building materials. So typically, they built things with concrete.
所以这座建筑有三个侧翼，每个侧翼以75度角倾斜，汇聚成看起来像金字塔的形状，有3000个房间，1000英尺高。它本应是一个工程奇迹，证明朝鲜优于韩国。唯一的问题是朝鲜人对各种建筑材料缺乏专业知识和经验。所以通常情况下，他们用混凝土建造东西。
And to gain that 1,000 feet height and all of that, you truly had to have an enormous base, and that kind of made it for an even larger kind of footprint, if you will. So almost right from the beginning, the construction project runs into problems. It was to be built in time for this major sporting event, but I understand it wasn't ready by the time the sporting event rolls around. Yes. In fact, it wasn't because of a variety of engineering issues, even though the government had spent you know, I assume billions of dollars. They'd also improved the airport. They'd kind of improved roads and everything. Unfortunately, at around this time, the Soviet Union was actually disintegrating and aid and investment that the North Koreans were accustomed to from the Soviet Union. They actually
为了达到1000英尺的高度，你确实需要一个巨大的底座，这使得它占地面积更大。所以几乎从一开始，这个建设项目就遇到了问题。它本应在这次重大体育赛事前及时建成，但我了解到在体育赛事到来时它并没有准备好。是的。事实上，由于各种工程问题，它确实没有准备好，尽管政府已经花费了，你知道，我假设是数十亿美元。他们还改善了机场。他们改善了道路等等。不幸的是，大约在这个时候，苏联实际上正在解体，朝鲜习惯从苏联获得的援助和投资。它们实际上
kind of dwindled to a trickle. And, you know, North Korea was headed for an economic crisis. So it was this economic crises that kind of led to the abandonment of this project. I see. So in 1992, this is five years after construction begins, the project is halted. And in fact, a crane is abandoned on top of the building. It must now look like a very strange pyramid. And the building just simply sits there. It sits unoccupied, vacant for decades.
减少到了涓涓细流。而且，你知道，朝鲜正走向经济危机。所以正是这种经济危机导致了这个项目的废弃。我明白了。所以1992年，也就是动工五年后，项目停工了。事实上，一台起重机被遗弃在建筑顶部。它现在一定看起来像一个非常奇怪的金字塔。而这座建筑就那样坐落着。它空置了数十年。
That's exactly right, Shankar. But by then, you know, you already have. had memes describing this hotel as the hotel of doom or the tower of failure and, you know, so on and so forth. And what this was was really an architectural testament to the excesses of the Pyongyang regime. So this massive structure sits today. It's basically a ghost hotel. It's, it must look eerie, Huggy. It truly is because the problem is the building was structurally unsound. Even though from the exterior the building may look sound, the interior is the problem. And because it was built with
完全正确，尚卡尔。但到那时，你知道，你已经有了描述这家酒店为“末日酒店”或“失败之塔”的梗，等等。这实际上是平壤政权过度行为的建筑见证。所以这座巨大的建筑今天依然存在。它基本上是一座鬼酒店。它一定看起来很阴森，哈吉。确实如此，因为问题在于这座建筑在结构上是不稳固的。尽管从外观上看，这座建筑可能看起来很稳固，但内部才是问题所在。而且因为它是由
concrete, it would take an enormous amount of time and expense to redo the ventilation systems and, you know, the air conditioning systems, all of which were created for 1980 specifications. So you say that the fire festival and this Hotel of Doom are examples of what researchers call poetry before plumbing. Unpack the term for me, Hagi. Yeah, thank you. You know, I should immediately give credit to my wonderful colleague who sadly passed away several years ago, Jim March.
混凝土建造的，重做通风系统和空调系统将花费巨大的时间和金钱，所有这些都是按照1980年的规格建造的。所以你说火人节和这座“末日酒店”是研究人员所说的“诗歌先于管道”的例子。为我解释一下这个术语，哈吉。好的，谢谢。你知道，我应该立即把功劳归于我那位几年前不幸去世的杰出同事吉姆·马奇。
He wrote a brilliant book. And that's kind of where he said, hey, leadership is a mix of poetry and plumbing. And he used poetry as a shorthand for purpose, if you will. Lofty goals, lofty visions and the like. And plumbing for operational details, efficiency, routines, and the like. And for him, you know, it was, how shall I put it? He saw this as part of like a perennial duality of leadership, the exuberant part of a leader's job, the poetry and the purpose,
他写了一本精彩的书。这就是他所说的，嘿，领导力是诗歌和管道的结合。他用“诗歌”作为目的的简写，如果你愿意的话。崇高的目标、崇高的愿景等等。而“管道”则是指运营细节、效率、常规等等。对他来说，你知道，它是，我该怎么说呢？他认为这是领导力永恒二元性的一部分，领导者工作中充满活力的部分，即诗歌和目的，
and the prosaic part of the job. And the prosaic part of the job had to do with simplicity, detail, and kind of making sure things kind of got done. And what the fire festival and the Hotel of Doom are compelling examples, of is how if we get seduced only by the poetry and we forget the plumbing, we are going to be in the grip of, frankly, an illusion. Poetry can be really sometimes a doorway to disaster. Huggie, I'm wondering, are there personal dimension?
以及工作中平淡的部分。而工作中平淡的部分与简单、细节以及确保事情完成有关。火人节和末日酒店是令人信服的例子，说明如果我们只被诗歌诱惑而忘记了管道，我们将陷入一种幻觉。诗歌有时真的可能是通往灾难的入口。哈吉，我想知道，这是否也有个人层面？
of this as well? Are there times in our personal lives when we can get caught up by the vision, by the poetry, by the passion of something, and forget about the prosaic, the mundane, the details? Easy to do that. Very easy to do that. And very easy to stumble into a disaster. I prefer to think of the poet and the plumber as two selves that all of us have. And so what we've got to kind of ask ourselves is which self is actually showing up. At home, if it's all plumbing and no poetry, my God, there's no laughter, there's no conversation, it's kind of boring. But at the same token, if it's all poetry and no plumbing, you know, who's going to fix the lights
我们个人生活中是否也有被愿景、诗歌、激情所吸引，而忘记了平淡、平凡、细节的时候？很容易做到这一点。非常容易。而且很容易陷入灾难。我更倾向于把诗人和管道工看作我们每个人都有的两个自我。所以我们必须问自己的是，哪个自我实际上在表现。在家里，如果全是管道而没有诗歌，天哪，没有欢笑，没有对话，那太无聊了。但同样，如果全是诗歌而没有管道，你知道，谁来修理灯光
and who's going to fix the water system, you know, all of those things, you're going to run into difficulty. So in that sense, our life is a perennial effort to kind of balance and toggle between our plumber selves and our poet selves. Can you talk a little bit about this idea in an organizational setting where we can get very enamored with the pleasure of brainstorming an idea or brainstorming a new startup instead of thinking about the nitty-gritty, the details that go into actually launching the startup? Completely. You immediately fall prey to a bias called the addition bias.
谁来修理供水系统，你知道，所有这些事情，你都会遇到困难。所以从这个意义上说，我们的生活是一种在我们的管道工自我和诗人自我之间平衡和切换的永恒努力。你能谈谈在组织环境中，我们可能会非常沉迷于头脑风暴一个想法或头脑风暴一个新创业公司的乐趣，而不是思考启动创业公司所需的细节吗？完全正确。你立即成为一种被称为“加法偏见”的偏见的牺牲品。
So very quickly you add things for people to do. They're already overwhelmed because of time poverty. I mean, where are they going to find the resources to do all of this? So very little actually gets done. I feel like everyone is familiar with the, with the, with the, brainstorming session at a company where, you know, everyone puts up sticky notes on a wall saying, here are the ideas that we should do. And there is something deeply pleasurable in doing that, and thinking about blue sky ideas of ways that you can change and things that you can
所以你很快就会增加人们要做的事情。他们已经因为时间贫困而不堪重负了。我的意思是，他们去哪里找资源来做所有这些事情？所以实际上很少有事情能完成。我觉得每个人都熟悉公司里的头脑风暴会议，你知道，每个人都在墙上贴上便签，说，这是我们应该做的想法。做这件事本身有一种深深的愉悦感，思考你可以改变和转化的方式的蓝天想法。
transform. But that is a far cry from actually making those transformations real. I love your description of the brainstorming experience, Shankar. Because when people think of what brainstorming is, it's kind of putting fun ideas and often implausible. ideas on the table. But brainstorming without constraints is a problem. How can you brainstorm without talking to a customer? You suggest that the launch some years ago of the healthcare.gov system illustrates this idea. Tell me what happened there, Huggie. Oh my God. You know, this was after President Obama signed the Affordable Care Act. And then there was a website that was to be launched and it was called health care.gov.
但这与真正实现这些转变相去甚远。我喜欢你对头脑风暴体验的描述，尚卡尔。因为当人们想到头脑风暴是什么时，它有点像把有趣的想法，通常是不可行的想法放在桌面上。但没有约束的头脑风暴是一个问题。你怎么能在不与客户交谈的情况下进行头脑风暴？你提到几年前healthcare.gov系统的发布说明了这个想法。告诉我那里发生了什么，哈吉。天哪。你知道，这是在奥巴马总统签署《平价医疗法案》之后。然后有一个网站要发布，它叫healthcare.gov。
The hope was that the platform would, you know, enroll lots of uninsured Americans, but the rollout was an exercise and complete disaster. As a matter of fact, on the first day that health care.gov was launched, four million unique visitors visited the portal, but only six were able to successfully register themselves. Can you imagine that? You know, and then over the next few days, their site had 8 million visitors, but only 1% enrolled in that healthcare plan. And even those who enrolled encountered lots of errors and so on and so forth. Because, you know, it's like healthcare.com was not a simple app. It was very complicated because it needed to integrate data from different sources.
希望该平台能让许多没有保险的美国人注册，但发布过程是一场彻底的灾难。事实上，在healthcare.gov发布的第一天，有400万独立访客访问了该门户网站，但只有6人能够成功注册。你能想象吗？你知道，然后在接下来的几天里，他们的网站有800万访客，但只有1%的人注册了该医疗计划。即使是那些注册的人也遇到了很多错误等等。因为，你知道，healthcare.gov不是一个简单的应用程序。它非常复杂，因为它需要整合来自不同来源的数据。
You needed data on social security numbers, data on income, and then you needed what the states were doing and all of that before matching people with private purveyors of insurance. You had to have ID verification. All of this is like pretty complex. And it's not just putting like an app out there. And that was why it actually ballooned into this tragic design. But subsequently, you know, it must be mentioned, there was remarkable recovery. The CTO of the Obama presidency, Todd Park, I think they changed the leadership, they fired a bunch of people. So lots of other things happened in order to retrieve ground. And eventually it did kind of do better, much better.
你需要社会安全号码数据、收入数据，然后你需要各州正在做的事情，所有这些都要在将人们与私人保险供应商匹配之前完成。你必须进行身份验证。所有这些都相当复杂。这不仅仅是发布一个应用程序。这就是为什么它最终膨胀成这种悲剧性的设计。但随后，你知道，必须提到的是，有显著的恢复。奥巴马总统任期的首席技术官托德·帕克，我想他们更换了领导层，解雇了一群人。所以为了挽回局面，发生了很多其他事情。最终它确实做得更好，好多了。
So you and your colleague, Bob Sutton, who is a former Hidden Brain guest, you both say that another reason, we tend to prioritize poetry over plumbing is that the feedback mechanisms are broken and problems are not being reported to leader. So people become silent and it creates the illusion that everything is working well? The reason you have illusion is
所以你和你的同事鲍勃·萨顿，他是《Hidden Brain》的前嘉宾，你们都说我们倾向于优先考虑诗歌而不是管道的另一个原因是反馈机制被破坏了，问题没有报告给领导。所以人们变得沉默，这造成了一切运作良好的错觉？你之所以有错觉是因为
30 years of research shows us that people who are powerful and who feel they have power, they actually don't search much. It's people without power that search and figure out why are things happening the way they are. The other thing is to your point, not only is there silence, people in power have an army of people making their life easy. So they also don't know how jobs, three levels beneath them are done.
30年的研究向我们表明，那些强大且感到自己有权力的人，他们实际上搜索得不多。是那些没有权力的人在搜索并弄清楚事情为什么会这样发生。另一件事是，正如你所说，不仅有沉默，掌权者还有一群人让他们的生活变得轻松。所以他们也不知道比他们低三级的工作是如何完成的。
So illusion hardens into impatience. Why couldn't we get it done yesterday and so on? And the moment you multiply illusion with impatience, what happens is the really competent doers, they go underground. because they know this is a fast-trained right to nowhere. So you have incompetent people who are available to help you proceed with whatever you're doing. And now you have incompetence, multiplying, impatience, and delusion. So even when you tell people up the hierarchy something wrong is happening, it's very difficult for them to register because they don't understand it.
所以错觉固化为不耐烦。为什么我们昨天不能完成它等等。当你把错觉乘以不耐烦时，真正能干的实干家就会转入地下。因为他们知道这是一列通往虚无的快车。所以你有无能的人可以帮助你继续做你正在做的任何事情。现在你有无能、乘以不耐烦和错觉。所以即使你告诉等级制度上方的人发生了什么错误，他们也很难察觉，因为他们不理解。
The canonical stories about the American automobile industry and the executives there, any time they had a car with a problem, they never had to go to the mechanic. I mean, it was immediately replaced. So you've no idea what it means for a person to go to the mechanic. And so you can actually see the disconnection that immediately kind of derails a lot of these plans and projects. and so on. Another reason we don't do enough plumbing is that we don't increase the amount of plumbing
关于美国汽车工业和那里的高管的经典故事是，任何时候他们有问题的车，他们从来不需要去修理工那里。我的意思是，它立即被更换了。所以你根本不知道一个人去修理工那里意味着什么。所以你可以看到这种脱节，它立即破坏了许多这些计划和项目。所以我们没有做足够的管道工作，另一个原因是随着我们从最初的愿景中成长和扩展，我们没有增加我们所需的管道数量。谈谈规模化的挑战，以及它如何给管道带来问题，哈吉。是的，你知道，对我来说，规模化就是重塑。我能传达的最简单的方式是鲍勃和我写了一个关于Uber前首席技术官的案例研究。
we will need as we grow and expand from our initial visions. Talk about the challenge of scaling, Huggie, and how that presents a problem for plumbing. Yeah, you know, scaling for me is reinvention. The simplest way in which I can telegraph this is Bob and I wrote a case study about the former CTO of Uber.
我们问了他一个简单的问题。我们说，嘿，你在Uber工作了多久？他看着我们说，四年。但感觉就像我为16家不同的公司工作过。他是什么意思？四年，你怎么会感觉你在为16家不同的公司工作？答案是每个季度Uber都是一家不同的公司。问题是改变管道涉及两件事。
And we asked him a simple question. We said, hey, how long have you worked at Uber? And he looks at us and said, four years. But it feels as though I work for 16 different companies. And what does he mean by that? Four years, how can you feel like you're working for 16 different companies? And the answer is every quarter Uber is a different company. And the problem is changing the plumbing involves two things.
不是安装管道，而是拆除旧管道，因为它是旧代码、旧规格、旧尺寸分布，你知道，所有这些东西。你能谈谈当问题没有得到解决，当有管道问题没有得到解决时，它们不仅仅是小问题，而是会级联并随着时间的推移变成更大的问题吗？绝对是。关键是修复管道是一个孤儿问题，而且不仅是一个孤儿问题。
It's not putting in plumbing, but it's taking out. the old plumbing too, because it's to old code, old specs, an old size distribution, you know, all of those things. Can you talk a bit about how when problems are not addressed, when there are plumbing problems that are not addressed, those don't just stay small problems, but they can cascade and become bigger problems over time? Absolutely. The key thing is fixing plumbing is an orphan problem, and not only is that an orphaned.
管道被低估了。因为管道工做什么？当你修理管道时，嗯，你在规避问题。它不像克服危机那样具有戏剧性的结果，诗歌在那种情况下很重要。你知道，他们召集了部队。他们做了这个，做了那个。所以这些人得到了很多补偿。诗人在危机后能够动员部队，但那些避免问题的管道工，人们不知道他们做了什么，它不可见。而且还有一些证据表明，组织中良好的管道工作也是性别化的，女性倾向于做更多这种工作，这也是它再次被低补偿的一个原因，
problem. Plumbing is undervalue. Because what do plumbers do? When you fix the plumbing, well, you're averting problem. It's not as dramatic as an outcome as overcoming a crisis or something like that, where poetry matters. You know, they rallied the troops. They did this and they did that. And so those people get compensated a lot. The poets are able to mobilize the troops after, you know, are crises, but the plumbers who avoid problems, people don't know what they did, it's not visible. And there's also some evidence that good plumbing work in organizations is also gendered, that women tend to do more of this, and which is one reason it gets kind of undercompensated again,
悲剧性地。但如果你不解决问题，你知道，即使在我的家庭环境中，假设你的炉子上有一个旋钮基本上不能正常工作，你懒得去修理它。后天，你家里可能会着火，因为你没有修理那个旋钮。所以不仅仅是管道问题有随着时间推移升级和变大的方式。我认为这种滚雪球的特性正是我们必须将其扼杀在摇篮里的原因，你知道，这就是重点。你知道，一盎司的预防当然胜过一磅的治疗。但很多管道问题是，我该怎么说呢？
tragically. But if you don't fix a problem, you know, let's say even in my, in a home setting, Let's say there is a knob on your stove that is basically not working properly and you can't be bothered to fix it. Day after tomorrow, you might have a fire in your house because you haven't fixed the knob. And so it's not just the plumbing problems have a way of escalating and becoming bigger over time. I think this snowballing characteristic is exactly why we have to nip it early in the butt, you know, which is the point. You know, an ounce of prevention, of course, is worth a ponder cure. But a lot of the plumbing problems are, how shall I put it?
它们非常非常容易被忽视。所以我们已经谈到了我们如何因为沉迷于诗歌而未能优先考虑管道。我想知道，有时诗歌本身，我们拥有的激情，是否可能阻止我们关注管道？是的，让我给你一个简单的例子。这实际上发生在法国的家乐福在日本。家乐福是一家总部位于法国的大型零售商。它将超市与百货商店结合在一起，类似于美国的塔吉特或沃尔玛商店。
They're very, very easy to kind of overlook. So we've talked about how we can fail to prioritize the plumbing because we're enamored of the poetry. I'm wondering, is it ever possible that sometimes the poetry itself, the passions that we have, can keep us from attending to the plumbing? Yes, let me give you a simple kind of example. This actually happened to Carrefour in Japan. Carfor is a big box retailer based in France. It combines a supermarket with a department store, similar to many Target or Walmart stores in the U.S.
所以家乐福进入了日本，他们建立了一堆商店。而且，你知道，诗意的想象是日本游客喜欢访问巴黎，他们喜欢逛商店等等。所以他们不一定需要去巴黎。你知道，我们会去那里做这件事。但讽刺的是，当他们真正开始建造商店时，展示的产品几乎是日本消费者可以从普通7-Eleven买到的东西。
So Carafour entered Japan, and they established a bunch of stores. And, you know, the poetic imagination was Japanese tourists. love visiting Paris, they love visiting the stores and so on. And so they don't need to go, you know, to Paris necessarily. You know, we'll come there and do that. But ironically, when they actually began to build out the stores, the products that were on display were pretty much what a Japanese consumer could get from the regular 7-Eleven.
所以人们最初有兴趣，说，嘿，我不需要从法国供应商那里买日本东西，即使它是家乐福。所以他们实际上不得不撤出。你看到了关注管道的难度。有很多事情会阻止我们实现目标。但有时，当我们追求激情时，阻碍我们的东西就是激情本身。当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何把管道做好。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
So there was initial interest in people kind of said, hey, I don't need to buy Japanese stuff from, you know, a French purveyor, even though it's caravore. And so they actually had to withdraw. You see the difficulty of attending to the plumbing. There are many things that can keep us from reaching our goals. But sometimes, the thing that gets in the way when we follow our passion is the passion itself. When we come back, how we can get the plumbing right. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你对让想法起步的机制有什么问题或评论吗？如果你愿意与《Hidden Brain》的听众分享你的想法和问题，请在手机上录制一段简短的语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件给我们，地址是Ideas@Hiddenbrain.org。两三分钟就足够了。使用主题行“管道”。再说一遍，那是Ideas@Hiddenbrain.org。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Do you have questions or comments about the mechanics of getting ideas off the ground? If you're willing to share your thoughts and questions with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a short voice memo on your phone and email it to us, at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Two or three minutes is plenty. Use the subject line, plumbing. Again, that's Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org.
想想你最喜欢的歌。它让你的心和灵魂感到电击。它就像一小剂魔法，瓶子里的闪电。但仔细听。你听到单个乐器以及投入其中的工作了吗？钢琴家不仅仅是设置了一个漂亮的编曲。他花了多年时间完善每一个音符。你看到吉他手为了完善你最喜欢的即兴重复段而把手指弹到骨头里的艰苦日子了吗？
Think about your favorite song. It makes your heart and soul feel electric. It's like a little dose of magic, lightning in a bottle. But listen harder. Do you hear the individual instruments and the work that went into each of them? The pianist didn't just set up a pretty arrangement. He spent years perfecting each note. Do you see the grueling days the guitarist spent strumming her fingers to the bone
在斯坦福大学商学院，哈吉·拉奥说，为了实现伟大的事情，我们需要把管道做好。我们需要魔法，但我们也需要关注平凡。哈吉，让我们谈谈一些因为拥抱管道而成功的组织实例。你说好的管道工会查看引擎盖下并收集大量信息，然后再开始修理东西，你讲了一个关于加州机动车辆管理局（DMV）曾经这样做过的故事。你能告诉我那个故事吗？是的，鲍勃和我很高兴写了一个关于加州DMV转型的故事，有两个人来自外部，史蒂夫·戈登就是其中之一。
to perfect your favorite riff in the song? At Stanford's Graduate School of Business, Hagi Rouse says that in order to achieve great things, we need to get the plumbing right. We need the magic, but we also need to focus on the mundane. Huggie, let's talk about some instances of organizations that are successful because they embrace the plumbing. You say that good plumbers look under the hood
让我和鲍勃着迷的是，史蒂夫访问了所有90个现场办公室，你知道，我对此有点惊讶，我有点怀疑抽样是否会有帮助，我的意思是，也许可以从90个现场办公室中抽取40个等等，但你知道，史蒂夫说了一些有趣的话，他说，看，你知道每个现场办公室都觉得它是独一无二的，所以当我们问他，你访问了所有这些现场办公室后，你的大发现是什么时，他实际上带回了一些简单而深刻的东西，他的认识是人们不需要去DMV，DMV可以去他们那里。所以你没有长队和人们等待等等。那么DMV怎么能去他们那里呢？一个答案是通过网络。你可以续订你的标签、驾照、支付注册费，所有这些都可以在线完成。如果你没有电脑和平板电脑等设备怎么办？
and collect lots of information before they start to fix things, and you tell a story about how the California Department of Motor Vehicles once did just that. Can you tell me that story? Yeah, Bob and I had the pleasure of writing a story about the transformation of the DMV in California and there were two people from the outside Steve Gordon being one of them
嗯，他们实际上想到了一个非常酷的主意。看看管道。人们去Safeway买杂货。让我们实际上有人们可以做所有这些事情的自助服务终端。他们做了什么？他们立即专注于通过去DMV的用户那里减少排队长度。他们减少排队长度的那一刻，
and what kind of fascinated me and Bob as well is Steve visited all 90 field offices and you know I was kind of a little surprised by that and I sort of wondered whether sampling might have helped I mean maybe one could have sampled 40 out of the 90 field offices or whatever but you know Steve said something interesting and he said look you know each field office feels it's unique and so when we asked him what was your big aha after you visited
人们，DMV的员工也有了更多的喘息空间。当你坐下来，只看到队伍蜿蜒曲折，人们不知道他们为什么在这里等等时，去上班并不容易。所以他们所做的一部分是他们也意识到仍然来到DMV的人可能信息不足。你知道，他们不知道你是否可以在DMV获得护照。所以他们放入了这个我们称之为“路径指南”的非常酷的东西。所以你排队，有一个人，你知道，他过来问，嘿，什么把你带到这里？
all of these field offices he actually came back with something that was simple and profound and his realization was people don't need to come to the DMV the DMV can go to them So you don't have long queues and people waiting and so on. So how can the DMV go to them? One answer is through the web. You can renew your tags, your driver's licenses, pay the registration fees, all of that online. What if you don't have access to computers and tablets and so on?
你说护照，他说，对不起，你知道，这是错误的地方，你必须去国务卿那里等等。所以他们很快就在做的是确保对员工的需求减少，对用户、消费者的需求也减少。现在，最重要的是，他们做了什么？他们恢复了善意。管道给人信心。你知道，我经常想到的类比，尚卡尔，你之前已经暗示过了，诗歌对我来说是计划婚礼，所有的乐趣、音乐、所有这些东西。
Well, they actually thought of a very cool thing. Look at the plumbing. People go to Safeway to buy groceries. Let's actually have kiosks where people can do all of that. What did they do? They concentrated immediately on reducing Q length by going to the users of the DMV. And the moment they reduced Q length,
管道是计划婚姻。在美国，我们会进行的对话是，嘿，我们要有一个银行账户还是两个，谁来支付什么，诸如此类的事情。如果你没有那种对话，你可以很容易地想象我们会遇到的问题范围。所以，组织中的员工，坦率地说，他们不太关心诗歌。或者让我这样说，诗歌越崇高，他们折扣它的倾向就越大。因为他们体验到的是矛盾。你说它可能都在那里，就像，看看我在说什么，这就像白天和黑夜，你知道。
people, the employees of the DMB also had more breathing room. It's not easy to come to work when you kind of sit down and you just see the line snaking, you know, and people don't know what they're here for and so on. So part of what they did is they also realized that the people still coming to the DMV could be ill-informed. You know, they don't know whether you can get a passport at the DMV. So they put in this very cool thing that we call a trail guide. So you stand in line, there's a guy, you know, who comes and says, hey, what brings you here?
所以如果我能引用婚礼的类比，员工不关心婚礼。因为新郎看起来和别人在一起，或者新娘从未出现，他们总是对婚姻会是什么样子感兴趣。这就是你必须一直帮助人们做的事情，让他们思考婚姻，而不仅仅是婚礼。我想知道在组织中做到这一点的一种方法是否是为诗歌留出特定时间，然后为管道留出特定时间。换句话说，你可能会花一个会议进行头脑风暴，
And you say passport, he says, I'm sorry, you know, this is the wrong place and you got to go to the secretary of state and so on and so forth. So very quickly what they're doing is they're actually making sure the demands on the staff are reduced and also demands on the users, the consumers are reduced. And now, most importantly, what have they done? They've restored goodwill. Plumbing gives confidence. You know, the analogy I often think of Shankar is, and you've hinted at it earlier, is poetry to me is planning the wedding, all the fun, the music, all of those things.
但你花另一个会议说，让我们思考机制，让我们思考执行。有没有可能在某些方面，你知道，为这些活动中的每一项留出特定时间可以帮助我们不忘记管道？绝对是。因为，你知道，当你留出时间时，你是在发出某种活动重要性的信号。不仅仅是留出时间，而是为人们提供一个脚手架。一个帮助他们做管道工作的脚手架。
Plumbing is planning the marriage. In America, the kind of conversations we would have is, hey, are we going to have one bank account or two, and who's going to pay for what, and those kinds of things. And if you don't have that kind of conversation, you can easily imagine the range of problems we'd encounter. And so, what employees in an organization, they don't care too much, frankly, about the poetry. Or let me put it this way, the more loftier the poetry, the greater their tendency to discount it. Because what they experience is the contradiction. You're saying it could be all in there, like, look at what I'm saying, it's like night and day, you know.
你知道，我推荐的脚手架是，嘿，你知道，假设你有一半的资源。假设你有四分之一的资源。你会做些什么不同的事情？你知道，什么会改变？你会停止做什么？我认为这就是你想要引导人们去做的事情。所以思考管道和诗歌的另一种方式，至少在你提到的背景下
So if I can recruit the wedding analogy, employees don't care about wedding. because the bridegroomy looked with somebody else or the bride never showed up, they're always interested in what's the marriage going to be. And that's what you've got to help people do all the time, get them to think about the marriage, not just the wedding. I'm wondering if one way to do this in organizations is to carve out specific times for the poetry and then to carve out specific time for the plumbing. So in other words, you might spend one session brainstorming,
所以如果我可以用婚礼来做类比，员工并不在乎婚礼，因为新郎可能和别人跑了，或者新娘根本没出现，他们真正关心的是婚后的生活会是什么样。这就是你必须时刻帮助人们去做的事情，让他们去思考婚姻，而不仅仅是婚礼。我想知道在组织中实现这一点的一种方法是否是为“诗意”留出特定的时间，然后再为“管道工程”留出特定的时间。换句话说，你可能花一次会议进行头脑风暴，
but you spend another session saying, let's think about mechanics, let's think about execution. Is it possible that in some ways, you know, carving out specific times for each of these activities can help us not forget about the plumbing? Absolutely. You know, because, you know, when you set aside time, you're signaling the importance of some activity. It's not only setting aside time, but providing people with a scaffold. A scaffold that helps them do the plumbing.
但你花另一次会议说，让我们思考一下机制，让我们思考一下执行。在某些方面，为这些活动中的每一项留出特定的时间，是否有可能帮助我们不忘记“管道工程”？当然可以。因为当你留出时间时，你就是在传达某项活动的重要性。这不仅是留出时间，更是为人们提供一个框架。一个帮助他们进行“管道工程”的框架。
You know, the kinds of scaffolds I'd recommend. and are, hey, you know, let's assume you have half the resources. Let's assume you have quarter the resources. What would you do differently? You know, what would change? What would you stop doing? And I think that's kind of what you want to orient people to do. So another way to think of plumbing and poetry, at least in the context that you've alluded
你知道，我推荐的那种框架是，嘿，假设你只有一半的资源。假设你只有四分之一的资源。你会做些什么不同的事情？你知道，会有什么改变？你会停止做什么？我认为这就是你想要引导人们去做的事情。所以，至少在你提到的语境下，思考“管道工程”和“诗意”的另一种方式是
to, Shankar is, poetry, if you're not careful, can result in a lot of addition, attention to plumbing, make sure that whatever you're adding is balanced by whatever you're subtracting. You say that good plumbers also anticipate problems before they arise, and one way to do this is with something called a premortem. What is a premortem, Huggie? The idea behind the premortem is, as the name itself implies, it's the opposite of a post-mortem. So we're not doing this after the event occurred to assign blame.
香卡，如果不小心的话，诗意可能会导致过多的添加，而忽视了管道维护。要确保你所添加的任何东西都能与你所减去的东西相平衡。你说优秀的管道工也会在问题出现之前就预见到它们，而做到这一点的方法之一就是进行“预演”（premortem）。什么是预演，哈吉？预演背后的理念，顾名思义，就是“尸检”（post-mortem）的反面。所以我们不是在事件发生后才进行这项工作来追究责任。
We're doing this even before we've spent any money you know so the premortem is actually an exercise in time travel and storytelling we have a brilliant dean of the medical school at Stanford Lloyd minor and he came here at roughly the same time I did and he reached out to me and he said you know you study scaling and he said I want to scale Stanford medicine and he had like a compelling idea he said hey we have two hospitals on campus at Stanford and we have lots of molecular biologists. Wouldn't it be cool if we put them into teams? They develop new drugs.
我们甚至在还没花钱之前就这么做了。你知道，预演实际上是一种时间旅行和讲故事的练习。斯坦福医学院有一位出色的院长劳埃德·迈纳（Lloyd Minor），他和我差不多同一时间来到这里。他找到我说：“你知道，你研究的是规模化，我想扩大斯坦福医学的规模。”他有一个引人注目的想法，他说：“嘿，我们在斯坦福校园里有两家医院，还有很多分子生物学家。如果我们把他们组成团队，让他们开发新药，那不是很酷吗？”
The Food and Drug Administration, the FDA, gives us approval, and we can run clinical trials here. But he said, I want to do a premortem. I said, okay. And so I said, we need roughly 10 people. I said, let's randomly choose a couple of molecular biologists, couple of MDs, a couple of nurses, couple of pharmacists, and a couple of medical administrators.
食品药品监督管理局（FDA）批准我们，我们就可以在这里进行临床试验。但他又说：“我想做一个预演。”我说：“好吧。”于是我说，我们需要大约10个人。我说，让我们随机挑选几位分子生物学家、几位医学博士、几位护士、几位药剂师和几位医疗行政人员。
I took these 10 people. I randomly assigned them into two groups. So in one group, they were in the premortem of failure. The other group was in the primortem of success. The dean hasn't raised a dime of money. He hasn't hired anybody. Now, to the five people in the premortem of failure, I gave them a made-up headline in a major newspaper dated six months out. And the headline read, debacle at Stanford Medicine, and the first two lines of the story were patients are dying in clinical trials. Of course, nothing like this has happened. It's all time travel and exercise and imagination. So I told these five people, you write a one-page story of the four or five key events that culminated in the headline. Conversely, to the people in the success condition,
我带了这10个人，把他们随机分成两组。一组进行“失败预演”，另一组进行“成功预演”。院长当时还没筹到一分钱，也没雇佣任何人。现在，对于进行“失败预演”的那五个人，我给了他们一份六个月后的主要报纸的虚构头条。头条写着：“斯坦福医学惨败”，故事的前两行是“患者在临床试验中死亡”。当然，这种事并没有发生。这完全是时间旅行和想象力的练习。所以我告诉这五个人，写一个一页纸的故事，描述导致这个头条的四五个关键事件。相反，对于处于“成功”条件下的那组人，
I gave them a different headline, and the headline said, Stanford drugs say, lives. And the first two lines were new drugs from Stanford University of saving the lives of the very young in the very old. And they had to write a story, one page, of the four or five events that led to the headline. I got ten stories. So to recap, the premortem that Huggie organized for the dean of Stanford's medical school included about 10 people. There were a mix of biologists, physicians, nurses, and hospital administrators. Half the people, were assigned to imagine a failed expansion of the medical school and half were tasked to imagine a successful expansion.
我给了他们一个不同的头条，头条写着：“斯坦福药物拯救生命”。前两行是“来自斯坦福大学的新药正在拯救年轻人和老年人的生命”。他们必须写一个一页纸的故事，描述导致这个头条的四五个事件。我收到了十个故事。总结一下，哈吉为斯坦福医学院院长组织的预演包括大约10个人。他们是生物学家、医生、护士和医院管理人员的混合体。一半人被分配去想象医学院的扩张失败，另一半人被分配去想象扩张成功。
What did the volunteers assigned to the failure group think would be the reasons the plan went astray? What did the volunteers assigned to the success group think would be the reasons the plan succeeded? Huggie assigned them their writing task and waited to see what would come back. Interestingly, whenever I've done the premortem for hiring a CEO acquisition,
被分配到失败组的志愿者认为计划偏离轨道的原因是什么？被分配到成功组的志愿者认为计划成功的原因是什么？哈吉给他们布置了写作任务，并等待结果。有趣的是，每当我为招聘首席执行官或收购进行预演时，
premortems of failure arrive first in your inbox. And that tells you immediately, Shankar, that people in the organization find it far more easier to imagine failure than success. And the molecular biologist said, look, you know, people die in clinical trials because there's a lag in the transfer of knowledge to doctors. The MD said, we'll tell you why this is happening. They said, you know, the molecular biologists sometimes they think the patient is only consuming the drug they've come up with. But patients take 10 other, 12 other drugs and interactions matter.
失败的预演总是最先出现在我的收件箱里。这立刻告诉你，香卡，组织里的人发现想象失败比想象成功要容易得多。分子生物学家说：“看，你知道，患者在临床试验中死亡是因为知识向医生转移存在滞后。”医学博士说：“我们会告诉你为什么会发生这种情况。他们说，你知道，分子生物学家有时认为患者只服用他们研发的那种药。但患者还服用其他10到12种药物，药物相互作用很重要。”
And if you don't pay attention to that, that would be a problem. The third thing was people wrote and said, you know, we're doing lots of low power trials, you know, taking notes on patients basically, you know, symptoms and the like and providing them to various organizations that want this to be done. And they said, we do so many of them, on top of them, if you have big trials, that would be a huge problem. On the success side, pretty much everybody wrote and said, Stanford succeeded because we subordinated our ego to the lives of patients. A number of people wrote and said Stanford succeeded because the molecular biologists consulted the statisticians early on in the design of the trial. The third thing that people wrote, which surprised the dean and the others was, Stanford succeeded because they hired very capable nurses who knew how to manage large-scale trials. Until then, I don't think there was any budgetary provision to hire nurses.
“如果你不注意这一点，那就会是个问题。”第三点是人们写道，我们正在进行许多低效能的试验，基本上就是记录患者的症状之类的信息，并提供给各种想要完成这项工作的组织。他们说，我们做了太多这样的试验，如果再加上大型试验，那将是一个巨大的问题。在成功方面，几乎每个人都写道，斯坦福之所以成功，是因为我们将自我置于患者生命之后。许多人写道，斯坦福之所以成功，是因为分子生物学家在试验设计之初就咨询了统计学家。第三点让院长和其他人感到惊讶的是，斯坦福之所以成功，是因为他们雇佣了非常有能力的护士，她们知道如何管理大规模试验。在那之前，我想还没有雇佣护士的预算规定。
And I remember asking the dean, what did this premortem do? And he put it beautifully. And he said, you know, when I came in, he said, I fell in love in the poetry of my job. He said, raising money, hiring world-class talent. And I said, now, and he looked at me and he said, I got to fix the plumbing here. It's part of my responsibility. So as you can see what the dean knew that he had the plumber self in him
我记得我问院长，这次预演有什么作用？他回答得非常漂亮。他说：“你知道，我刚来的时候，我爱上了这份工作的诗意。”他说，筹集资金，雇佣世界级的人才。我说：“现在呢？”他看着我说：“我得修理这里的管道。这是我的责任。”所以正如你所见，院长知道他内心既有管道工的一面，
and he had the poet's self. Coming in, he had activated the poet's self to the exclusion of the plumber self. What the premortem did was it activated the plumber self. It made them realize if they didn't fix this problem, stacking complex trials on an overstretched system would lead to a lot of problem. So it's an example of getting people to slow down and reflect.
也有诗人的一面。刚来时，他激活了诗人的一面，而排斥了管道工的一面。预演所做的就是激活了管道工的一面。这让他们意识到，如果不解决这个问题，在超负荷的系统上堆叠复杂的试验会导致很多问题。所以这是一个让人们慢下来并进行反思的例子。
So that's kind of what the primordom does. You say that another thing that good plumbers do is that they don't focus on hiring superstars but they hire Sherpas. What do you mean by Sherpas, Huggie? Yeah, we shouldn't always think of the stars, the two people who ascend Everest. Because without the 50 Sherpas,
这就是预演的作用。你说优秀的管道工做的另一件事是，他们不专注于雇佣超级明星，而是雇佣“夏尔巴人”（向导）。你所说的夏尔巴人是什么意思，哈吉？是的，我们不应该总是想到那些明星，即那两个登上珠穆朗玛峰的人。因为如果没有那50个夏尔巴人，
they're going to have done very much. So their performance, it's the outcome of a team, in this case, a very large team. And so it's the Sherpers that matter. It's the Sherpers that need to get rewarded. So what I always ask people is, if you want to really hire good Sherpers, look at two things. One is, how generous are they? Because without generosity, it's very hard to do much in organizations. So that's one thing you've got to do.
他们根本做不了什么。所以他们的表现是一个团队的结果，在这种情况下，是一个非常大的团队。所以重要的是夏尔巴人。需要得到奖励的是夏尔巴人。所以我总是问人们，如果你真的想雇佣好的夏尔巴人，看看两件事。一是他们有多慷慨？因为没有慷慨，在组织里很难做成什么事。所以这是你必须做的第一件事。
The other is how much energy do they have? Positive energy. You know, how much do they bring it? And in a lot of organizations, quite honestly, people don't know who their best Sherpas are. I've actually had to go to organizations and tell them, if you really want to find your best Sherpas, come through their LinkedIn pages,
另一件事是他们有多少能量？积极的能量。你知道，他们带来了多少能量？在很多组织里，老实说，人们不知道谁是他们最好的夏尔巴人。我实际上不得不去一些组织告诉他们，如果你真的想找到你最好的夏尔巴人，翻翻他们的领英（LinkedIn）页面，
you'll see them doing a lot for the community. They're volunteering for the church, the Little League, and they're doing all these things. They have so much energy. how come that's not being channeled inside the organization? And I think those are the people who have contact with ground reality. They're observing interactions,
你会看到他们为社区做了很多事。他们为教会、少年棒球联盟做志愿者，他们做了所有这些事情。他们有如此多的能量。为什么这些能量没有在组织内部得到引导？我认为这些人与现实有接触。他们观察互动，
they're having the interactions themselves. They do things above and beyond the call of duty. You make a point about good plumbers. They're not afraid to get their hands dirty. They don't just notice the bad stuff or anticipated. they actively go looking for it. Tell me the story of Matthew Ridgeway, Hagee. Matthew Ridgeway, for me, arguably, was the best U.S. general in the 20th century.
他们自己也在进行互动。他们做的事情超出了职责范围。你提到了关于优秀管道工的一点：他们不怕弄脏手。他们不仅注意到坏事或预见到坏事，他们还会主动去寻找坏事。给我讲讲马修·李奇微（Matthew Ridgeway）的故事吧，哈吉。对我来说，马修·李奇微可以说是20世纪最伟大的美国将军。
Ridgeway was actually a divisional commander in World War II. And Ridgeway actually shot into the national limelight when Truman fired MacArthur and appointed Ridgway as the commander-in-chief of all forces in Korea, South Korea. By then, the Chinese offensive had already pushed the U.S. troops back. And there was even a talk of like a Dunkirk-like scenario unfolding. Can you imagine your Ridgeway? I mean, you've got like thousands of demotivated, de-motivated, demoralized tired troops. You can't ask your boss for more fresh troops from the US.
李奇微实际上是二战期间的师长。当杜鲁门解雇麦克阿瑟并任命李奇微为驻韩国所有部队的总司令时，李奇微才真正进入了全国的聚光灯下。到那时，中国军队的攻势已经将美军推了回去。甚至有人谈论像敦刻尔克那样的场景即将上演。你能想象你是李奇微吗？我的意思是，你有成千上万士气低落、疲惫不堪的部队。你不能向你的老板要求从美国调来更多的新鲜部队。
That'll take six months to come there. By then, it'll all be decided. And the marvel behind what Ridgeway did was the same overwhelmed, demoralized group of people. Ridgeway actually got them to move and push the Chinese and the others. And how did he do it. You know, there are lots of things he did. I just want to give our, you know, listeners, a couple of things he did. One of the very first things, Richel realizes, is, you know, I've never fought in Korea. I don't even know how the land looks like. Where are mountains? Where are rivers? Where are lakes? So he actually pursuits a bomber pilot to take him on as a navigator and says, I'll help you navigate. I just want to see what's ahead. And, you know, there he is.
那需要六个月才能到达。到那时，一切都已成定局。李奇微所做之事的奇迹在于，他让这群同样不知所措、士气低落的人动了起来，并反击了中国军队和其他人。他是怎么做到的？你知道，他做了很多事情。我只想给我们的听众讲几件他做过的事。李奇微意识到的第一件事是：“我从未在韩国打过仗。我甚至不知道地形是什么样子。山在哪里？河在哪里？湖在哪里？”所以他实际上说服了一名轰炸机飞行员带他作为领航员，并说：“我会帮你导航。我只是想看看前面有什么。”然后，他就坐在那里。
and he actually now understands, oh my God, there's this complicated landscape. Now, what he does then is fascinating. He calls all of these commanders, commanding troops, and he asks them questions about their understanding of the landscape. Hey, what do you think is I had 25 miles from us? If the guy said, you know, I don't know, or I don't know that there's a river there that needs to be crossed or a lake or a mountain or whatever it is, he fired them on the spot. And he'd say, you're jeopardizing my men. And the most interesting thing about example of plumbing was he didn't stand there and give
他现在真正理解了，天哪，这是一个复杂的地形。然后他做了一件引人入胜的事。他召集了所有指挥部队的指挥官，询问他们对地形的理解。嘿，你认为我们前方25英里处是什么？如果那个人说：“我不知道”，或者“我不知道那里有一条需要跨越的河流、湖泊或山脉”，他会当场解雇他们。他会说：“你在危及我的士兵。”关于管道维护最有趣的例子是，他没有站在那里发表
great speeches like Patton might have done or somebody else might have done. Ridgeway always drove in a jeep without fighter escort. And they would say, you know, you need fighter escort. You know, my men are being shot at, I think I can do okay. But any time he would meet an American soldier, many of whom were. young kids 19, 2021. The first thing in the United States, man, they're working in bitter cold in Korea. They can't even hold the carbine up. It's so cold. The hands are frozen. So at the back of his Jeep, he would always have gloves. And any time he saw a young soldier with bare hands
像巴顿那样伟大的演讲，或者其他人可能会做的那样。李奇微总是开着一辆没有战斗护卫的吉普车。他们会说：“你需要战斗护卫。”他说：“我的士兵正在被射击，我想我能应付。”但每当他遇到美国士兵时，其中许多是19、20、21岁的孩子。在美国，他们是在韩国的严寒中工作。他们甚至拿不住卡宾枪。太冷了。手都冻僵了。所以他的吉普车后面总是放着手套。每当他看到一个年轻士兵赤手空拳
clutching a carbine, he would always give them gloves. And you can imagine. symbolically what giving gloves to a cold 19-20-year-old soldier meant. Good plumbers take the time to think about the dirty work involved in running their ventures. They don't just have their heads in the clouds. They roll up their sleeves and dig into the muck. In other words, they don't get so caught up in the poetry that they forget about the plumbing. about the plumbing. However, sometimes the reverse can also happen.
抓着卡宾枪，他总是会给他们手套。你可以想象，给一个寒冷中19、20岁的士兵手套在象征意义上意味着什么。优秀的管道工会花时间思考经营企业所涉及的脏活累活。他们不仅是眼高手低。他们卷起袖子，深入泥潭。换句话说，他们不会沉迷于诗意而忘记了管道维护。然而，有时情况也会反过来。
It's possible to get so granular, so stuck in the details, that you forget the reason behind what you are doing. You no longer see the poetry. The challenge, of course, is not to replace poetry with plumbing, but to combine poetry and plumbing. That's the topic of a special episode we have on Hidden Brain Plus. If you're a subscriber, that episode, is available right now. It's titled Finding the Poetry in Plumbing. If you're not yet
你可能会变得过于细致，过于陷入细节，以至于忘记了你所做之事的初衷。你不再看到诗意了。当然，挑战不在于用管道维护取代诗意，而在于将诗意和管道维护结合起来。这就是我们在《Hidden Brain Plus》特别节目中讨论的主题。如果你是订阅者，该集现在就可以收听。标题是《在管道维护中寻找诗意》。如果你还没有
signed up, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, please go to apple.com slash hiddenbrain. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org and apple.com slash hidden brain. Hagi Rao is the co-author with Bob Sutton of the Friction Project, how smart leaders make the right things easier and the wrong things harder and scaling up excellence, getting to more without settling for less. Hagi Rao, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so very much, Shankar. If you're willing to share your thoughts and questions with the Hidden Brain audience,
注册，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。再说一遍，是 support.hiddenbrain.org 和 apple.com/hiddenbrain。哈吉·拉奥（Hagi Rao）是《摩擦项目：聪明领导者如何让正确的事情变得更容易，让错误的事情变得更难》以及《扩大卓越：在不妥协的情况下实现更多》一书与鲍勃·萨顿（Bob Sutton）的合著者。哈吉·拉奥，非常感谢你今天参加《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢你，香卡。如果你愿意与《Hidden Brain》的听众分享你的想法和问题，
please record a short voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Two or three minutes is plenty. Use the subject line, plumbing. Again, that's Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's a narrative that we hear over and over again in news reporting and on social media. People are more divided than ever, by class, by education, and especially by political beliefs.
请在手机上录制一段简短的语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至 Ideas@hiddenbrain.org。两三分钟就足够了。主题行请使用“plumbing”（管道）。再说一遍，是 Ideas@hiddenbrain.org。你正在收听的是《Hidden Brain》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们在新闻报道和社交媒体上反复听到这样一种叙事：人们比以往任何时候都更加分裂，按阶级、教育程度，尤其是政治信仰。
We see evidence for this narrative in lots of places. People ignore those who disagree with them or gaze upon their political opponents with a mixture of bewilderment, contempt, and anger. What we hear less often are ideas for how to change this narrative. Is it possible to actually find common ground with someone whose worldview is the polar opposite of your own? How can we actually persuade someone else of our point of view?
我们在很多地方都看到了这种叙事的证据。人们无视那些与他们意见不合的人，或者以一种困惑、蔑视和愤怒的混合情绪注视着他们的政治对手。我们较少听到的是如何改变这种叙事的想法。是否真的有可能与一个世界观与你截然相反的人找到共同点？我们如何才能真正说服别人接受我们的观点？
What would it take for us to be persuaded by theirs? We pondered these questions some time ago with Rob Willer. He's a sociologist at Stanford University, and he joined us for an episode titled, Win Hearts, Then Minds. Today, he returns to the show to answer listener questions about engaging with people who are different from us. Rob Willer, welcome back to Hidden Brain.
我们需要什么才能被他们的观点说服？前段时间，我们与罗伯·威勒（Rob Willer）一起思考了这些问题。他是斯坦福大学的社会学家，他参加了我们一集名为《先赢人心，再赢头脑》的节目。今天，他回到节目中回答听众关于与不同背景的人接触的问题。罗伯·威勒，欢迎回到《Hidden Brain》。
Thanks for having me. Rob, in our earlier conversation, we talked about how when you were a kid, you moved from Kansas to South Carolina, the community you moved to was, politically speaking, very different from the one you'd left, and it was something of a culture shock. What were some of the things that stood out to you when you first arrived in South Carolina? Well, when I moved from Kansas, South Carolina, a key thing was that I was moving from
谢谢邀请。罗伯，在我们之前的谈话中，我们谈到了你小时候从堪萨斯州搬到南卡罗来纳州，你搬到的社区在政治上与你离开的社区非常不同，这是一种文化冲击。当你第一次到达南卡罗来纳州时，有哪些事情让你印象深刻？嗯，当我从堪萨斯州搬到南卡罗来纳州时，关键的一点是我从
this small college town, Lawrence, Kansas that was very politically, culturally, progressive, not that religious, you know, fairly secular. and I moved to South Carolina in 1988 and found myself in just a very different political, cultural environment. And a place that was characterized as much as anything by deep scars from racial segregation, Jim Crow, and even the Civil War, even the wounds of the Civil War were still healing on the surface. And it was for me just really striking to start to be interacting every day with people who might have racial prejudices, hearing the N-word on the playground, just was really, really shocking. And also just the degree of racial segregation that just happened
那个政治上、文化上非常进步、不太宗教化、相当世俗的小大学城劳伦斯搬了出来。我在1988年搬到了南卡罗来纳州，发现自己处于一个完全不同的政治和文化环境中。那个地方最显著的特征是种族隔离、吉姆·克劳法（Jim Crow）留下的深刻伤痕，甚至连内战的创伤在表面上都还在愈合。对我来说，每天与可能有种族偏见的人互动，在操场上听到“黑鬼”（N-word）这个词，真的非常非常令人震惊。还有那种自发发生的种族隔离程度，
spontaneously, even amongst 10, 11, 12-year-old kids. People were getting signals about who was supposed to interact with whom, and they were following them. Our teachers had, you know, at least half of them had taught in racially segregated schools. Schools had integrated less than 20 years earlier. All the kids I was going to school with, basically their parents had gone to all black or all white schools. And so it was really striking to me coming from a progressive community where the kind of moral battle of the 60s around civil rights was fairly settled. And if you expressed racial prejudice in public, you were a moral or social pariah in that community. And it just wasn't the same way in the place I'd moved to.
即使在10、11、12岁的孩子中间也是如此。人们接收到关于谁应该与谁互动的信号，他们就照做了。我们的老师中至少有一半曾在种族隔离的学校教过书。学校在不到20年前才实现融合。和我一起上学的孩子们，基本上他们的父母都上过全黑人或全白人的学校。所以，对于来自一个进步社区的我来说，这真的很令人震惊，因为在那里，60年代关于民权的道德斗争已经基本解决了。如果你在公共场合表达种族偏见，你就会成为那个社区的道德或社会弃儿。而在我搬到的地方，情况并非如此。
Did you find yourself getting into arguments with people, Rob? I did, yeah. As much as anything about race and religion, you know, the things that we had the starkest differences on, there were also, and still are, deeply held beliefs that I would encounter about how the poor were responsible for their own fate and didn't deserve sympathy and just a lot of cultural beliefs that were very new to me. and for me very objectionable. And my first reaction on this was to debate. You know, I've been raised in this very intellectual household,
罗伯，你发现自己会和别人争论吗？是的，确实。关于种族和宗教，你知道，我们在这些问题上有最鲜明的差异，还有，现在仍然有，我遇到的关于穷人如何对自己的命运负责、不值得同情以及许多对我来说非常新颖且非常令人反感的文化信仰。我对此的第一反应是辩论。你知道，我是在一个非常知识分子的家庭中长大的，
and I came right back at a lot of these views to the extent that I could without becoming like an outcast in my community. And that was a really intense and rich experience because I didn't find I was changing a lot of folks' minds. So I think many of us approach disagreements and disputes the way you did, as if there are a debate that we can either win or lose.
我直接反驳了许多这些观点，只要我不至于成为社区里的弃儿。那是一次非常强烈且丰富的经历，因为我发现我并没有改变多少人的想法。所以我认为我们许多人处理分歧和争端的方式和你一样，就好像这是一场我们可以赢或输的辩论。
And so we believe that if we can just present our case clearly and have the best argument and the clearest facts, we're going to persuade the other person of our point of view. You've learned over the years, not just when you moved to South Carolina, but later on when you became a researcher, that this does not tend to work. Why not, Rob? Well, for one, just coming right back at somebody with another set of facts and an alternate way to reason about some issues,
因此我们相信，如果我们能清楚地陈述我们的理由，拥有最好的论据和最清晰的事实，我们就能说服对方接受我们的观点。多年来，你不仅在搬到南卡罗来纳州时，而且后来当你成为研究人员时，你了解到这往往行不通。为什么不行，罗伯？嗯，首先，直接用另一套事实和另一种推理方式来反驳某人，
is a recipe for competition, for making somebody mad and defensive in the face of your arguments. And that might play in a high school debate round where there's a judge who's paying attention to the quality of the arguments. And I was a high school debater and, you know, refined those skills, if you'll call them that, in debate tournaments weekend after weekend for years. But that's not really, as it turns out, a great way to change a person's mind. it just puts them off generally and maybe makes them mad and could even entrench their views. And for me, the more helpful experience in terms of learning something about persuasion and how it can really work in the real world was my experience working as a union organizer.
这是竞争的秘诀，会让某人在你的论点面前感到愤怒和防御。这可能在高中辩论赛中有效，因为那里有评委关注论点的质量。我曾是一名高中辩手，你知道，周末复周末地在辩论赛中磨练这些技能。但事实证明，这并不是改变一个人想法的好方法。它通常只会让他们反感，甚至可能让他们愤怒，甚至可能加深他们的观点。对我来说，在学习说服力以及它如何在现实世界中真正发挥作用方面，更有帮助的经历是我作为工会组织者的工作。
So in graduate school, I went to graduate school at Cornell University and was very involved in a union organizing drive for graduate students there. And I got exposed to what I think of as the dominant. and culture of organizing in the U.S. and I assume elsewhere, which is not one of, oh, you disagree with me. Let's debate. But instead, you kind of show up and you say, hey, we're organizing a union and we need you. So what are your questions? Let's do this. We'd really like to sign you up. And it's a very positive, big tent, inclusive approach to political engagement that almost suggests just from the beginning, like, we're on the same side, and I'm just hopeful we can line up on this as well.
在研究生院，我在康奈尔大学读研究生，并非常参与了那里研究生的工会组织运动。我接触到了我认为是美国乃至其他地方占主导地位的组织文化，这不是一种“哦，你不同意我的观点，让我们辩论吧”的文化。相反，你会出现并说：“嘿，我们正在组织一个工会，我们需要你。你有什么问题吗？让我们这样做吧。我们真的很想让你加入。”这是一种非常积极、包容、大范围的政治参与方式，从一开始就暗示着“我们站在同一边，我只是希望我们也能在这件事上达成一致”。
Really the opposite of debating where you're like, I'm on my side, you're on your side, and I'm going to try to embarrass you with the quality of my arguments. I think many people struggle to listen and put themselves in the shoes of someone whose views they find either factually wrong or morally wrong. We received an email about this from a listener named Scott who writes, I find myself not engaging with the opposite side and political debates with certain friends. It sounds easy to certainly reframe the logical argument
这确实与辩论相反，在辩论中你会说：“我站在我这边，你站在你那边，我要用我论点的质量让你难堪。”我认为许多人难以倾听并设身处地为那些他们认为在事实或道德上错误的人着想。我们收到了一封来自听众斯科特的电子邮件，他写道：“我发现自己在与某些朋友的政治辩论中不愿与对方接触。重新构建逻辑论点以更有效地参与听起来很容易，
in an effort to engage more effectively, but what if they are arguing from the point of view of someone who is okay with lying, cheating, stealing, or admitted racism? In other words, they find those vices okay in their logic and, frankly, admit to the vices. Is it better not to engage, call them out, or try to understand their point of view?
但如果他们是从一个可以接受撒谎、欺骗、偷窃或承认种族主义的人的角度进行辩论呢？换句话说，他们在逻辑上认为这些恶习是可以接受的，并且坦率地承认这些恶习。是不参与、揭露他们，还是尝试理解他们的观点更好？”
What do you think, Rob? I mean, I think it's an excellent question, and it's really hard. My first thought is the last thing that Scott highlights here of try to draw them out, try to get a better sense of why they have the views that they have as much as possible without debating it first. And so if they say they don't care about someone they voted for openly lying and that being more or less objectively proven, like ask them why they don't care about that or like, what is it that outweighs that for them that leads them to vote the way they do?
你觉得呢，罗伯？我的意思是，我认为这是一个极好的问题，而且真的很难。我的第一个想法是斯科特在这里强调的最后一点：尝试引导他们，尽可能在不先进行辩论的情况下，更好地了解他们为什么会有这些观点。所以如果他们说他们不在乎他们投票支持的人公开撒谎，而且这或多或少被客观证明了，那就问他们为什么不在乎，或者是什么东西对他们来说比这更重要，导致他们以那种方式投票？
This has a few functions, like the most obvious function is you're showing some sort of interest in their perspective. So you're setting a decent kind of foundation for an interaction that could go somewhere. You're showing some, you know, basic respect. But you're also getting a lot of really valuable information. You're figuring out where they're coming from and why they think the way they do how they're balancing things in their head, or maybe there's something sacred involved related to religion or something like that that really matters to them. You know, you can figure out like why, you know, they have the views that they do. And you're going to need that if you're going to move them at all or even tolerate them. You know, if somebody has expressed
这有几个功能，最明显的功能是你表现出对他们观点的某种兴趣。所以你为一段可能有所进展的互动奠定了不错的基础。你表现出了一些基本的尊重。但你也获得了大量非常有价值的信息。你弄清楚了他们来自哪里，为什么他们会那样想，他们在脑海中是如何权衡事情的，或者也许涉及与宗教相关的东西，这对他们来说真的很重要。你知道，你可以弄清楚为什么他们会有这些观点。如果你想动摇他们，甚至只是容忍他们，你都需要这些。你知道，如果有人表达了
tolerance for racism, that's a hard thing to accept. One of the things that you've come to realize over the years is that when we develop our views on a topic, the information that we're working with is often very different than the information that other people have. Talk about this idea that beneath the surface of some of our disagreements, we actually just simply have different sources of information. Yeah, that's exactly right. And I think this is a hugely overlooked aspect of empathy and connecting. We tend to think of empathy in terms of compassion and sympathy for other people, and then also perspective taking. Like, am I trying to think from your perspective? But one thing that gets, I think, overlooked there that's maybe more structural, that adheres in the
对种族主义的容忍，那是一件很难接受的事情。多年来你意识到的一件事是，当我们发展对某个话题的看法时，我们所使用的信息往往与其他人拥有的信息非常不同。谈谈这个观点：在我们的一些分歧表面之下，我们实际上只是拥有不同的信息来源。是的，完全正确。我认为这是同理心和建立联系方面一个被严重忽视的方面。我们倾向于从对他人的同情和怜悯，以及换位思考的角度来考虑同理心。比如，我是否在尝试从你的角度思考？但有一点我认为被忽视了，这可能更具结构性，存在于
structure of the situation and people having just fundamentally different experiences of their lives, is that there's also, there are also these big information gaps. Try as I might to take your perspective. There are fundamental things I don't know about your life that get in the way of me doing so authentically or accurately. well. And so this is a huge barrier. And so you can even have people that are fairly motivated to consider one another's perspective, but they just have such different lived experiences that they can't construct a narrative to understand how this person they disagree with is saying something that sounds so vile and objectionable.
情况的结构中，人们对生活的体验有着根本的不同，那就是也存在这些巨大的信息鸿沟。尽管我尽力站在你的角度思考，但关于你的生活，我有一些根本性的东西不知道，这阻碍了我真实或准确地这样做。所以这是一个巨大的障碍。因此，即使人们有相当大的动力去考虑彼此的观点，但他们有着如此不同的生活经历，以至于他们无法构建一个叙事来理解这个他们不同意的人为什么会说出听起来如此卑劣和令人反感的话。
One of the interesting paradoxes here is that I think all of us who have ever been in a political debate can see how we feel like we are under threat. So to us, it feels as if our opponents are trying to do us harm, want to do us harm, and we feel vulnerable and in a position of threat. Much harder to see that our opponents feel exactly the same. I totally agree. And this is part of why my first piece of advice I often give folks who ask me about how do you handle these long-stained disagreements that adhere in families or in friendships that you want to maintain. One of my first piece of advice is think about your physiological reaction to the situation and deal with that maybe first. And so if somebody's saying something that seems offensive
这里一个有趣的悖论是，我认为所有经历过政治辩论的人都能看出我们是如何感到自己受到威胁的。对我们来说，感觉就像我们的对手试图伤害我们，想要伤害我们，我们感到脆弱并处于受威胁的地位。很难看出我们的对手也有完全相同的感觉。我完全同意。这就是为什么我经常给那些问我如何处理家庭或友谊中长期存在的、你想维持的分歧的人的第一条建议是：考虑你对这种情况的生理反应，也许先处理那个。所以如果有人说了一些似乎冒犯了
to you, take a beat, take a pause, ask them an open-ended question, draw them out, have them fill the space with some more information you can take in. And in that time, see if you can settle yourself well enough to make the argument you're going to, you know, tomorrow wish you it made rather than the one that feels like the one you need to say in that moment. Because when we're sensing like a really significant disagreement that's freighted with all this moral baggage, when we see that coming, I mean, most of us, we start to get short of breath. Our heart rate quickens. Our diaphragm is up higher, you know, inside of our chest. And we're breathing shallowly and we're just not calm.
你的话，停顿一下，暂停一下，问他们一个开放式的问题，引导他们，让他们用更多你可以吸收的信息填补空间。在那段时间里，看看你是否能让自己平静下来，从而做出你明天会希望自己做出的论点，而不是那种感觉你在那一刻必须说的论点。因为当我们感觉到一个带有所有这些道德包袱的重大分歧时，当我们看到它到来时，我的意思是，我们大多数人，开始呼吸短促。我们的心率加快。我们的横膈膜在胸腔内位置更高。我们呼吸浅薄，我们并不冷静。
You know, we're ready to fight or to flee or what have you. And if you can take that beat and try to relax the diaphragm, take a deeper breath, listen, and think about what you really would like to say to the person, you'll do better. It'll be better for really all involved, but for you and achieving your goals. We received a message from a listener named Kevin that I think speaks to the emotional aspect of engaging with other people. Here he is. I've been an activist for over 50 years.
你知道，我们准备好战斗或逃跑等等。如果你能停顿一下，试着放松横膈膜，深呼吸，倾听，并思考你真正想对那个人说什么，你会做得更好。这对所有相关人员，尤其是对你实现目标来说，都会更好。我们收到了一位名叫凯文的听众发来的信息，我认为这触及了与他人接触的情感层面。他是这样说的：“我做了50多年的活动家。”
And one of the things that I try to do is in a conversation with somebody is actually make physical contact and a respectful, you know, shake hands, hand on the shoulder, you know, proximity, touching kind of thing. And I find that it helps establish and defuse almost like an elaborate. electrical charge release, making friends, and say, we're really on the same side here. We're both human. Let's see if we can find someplace that we agree. What do you make of Kevin's approach, right?
“我尝试做的一件事是，在与某人交谈时，实际上进行身体接触，一种尊重的握手、拍拍肩膀、亲近、触摸之类的事情。我发现这有助于建立和化解，几乎就像一种复杂的电荷释放，结交朋友，并说，我们真的站在同一边。我们都是人类。让我们看看能否找到我们同意的地方。”罗伯，你觉得凯文的方法怎么样？
Well, I think Kevin's exactly right. And I can kind of sense that he's an experienced organizer, that he's foregrounding this idea of making a human-to-human connection prior to getting into the issues at hand. it's very true. Of course, this is something we see skilled politicians do a lot. You know, Bill Clinton famously had different levels. He'd put his supporting hand on your arm when he was doing a handshake. And God forbid, you got the one hand handshake from Bill Clinton. That means you were just beneath reproach, I gather. But if he's coming up with the left hand, like high on your right shoulder, that means like he's really trying to affiliate with you and you're going to feel it. Of course, one has to be very careful with this to be appropriate.
嗯，我认为凯文完全正确。我能感觉到他是一位经验丰富的组织者，他在处理手头的问题之前，将建立人与人之间的联系这一理念放在了首位。这非常正确。当然，这是我们看到熟练的政治家经常做的事情。你知道，比尔·克林顿很有名，他有不同的层次。当他握手时，他会把支撑的手放在你的手臂上。天哪，如果你得到了比尔·克林顿的单手握手，那意味着你简直无可救药。但如果他用左手，高高地放在你的右肩上，那意味着他真的在试图与你建立联系，你会感觉到的。当然，在做这件事时必须非常小心，要得体。
You can't initiate this in door-to-door canvassing necessarily, maybe a handshake you can do. But, you know, like it would be bad, for example, to start off a conversation where you're giving your appeal while gently rubbing the temples of the person you're speaking. I wouldn't advise that. Kevin wouldn't advise that. You know, it's interesting when we think about just the ways in which humans interact with each other. We do some of this naturally, right? when we are talking with people, we invite friends over to our home, for example, and they come into our home, we shake hands with them, we give them a hug, where basically we demonstrate
你不能在挨家挨户的拉票活动中随意发起这种接触，也许握手是可以的。但是，例如，在进行诉求时，一边轻轻揉搓你正在交谈的人的太阳穴，一边开始对话，那会很糟糕。我不建议这样做。凯文也不会建议这样做。你知道，当我们思考人类相互交流的方式时，这很有趣。我们自然会做一些这样的事情，对吧？当我们与人交谈时，例如，我们邀请朋友到家里，他们来到我们家，我们与他们握手，我们给他们一个拥抱，我们基本上通过触摸证明
through touch that we are affiliated with one another. And I think Kevin's insight is that perhaps we don't feel that moment of affiliation right up front, but in some ways going through the actions can get us in a mind state where we feel like we have more affiliation. Yeah, that's interesting. I hadn't actually even thought of that, that part of why you might do this would be for yourself, you know, that put yourself in the right mindset of curiosity, openness, an interest in the other person as a person. It reminds me a little bit of this research on deep canvassing technique of door-to-door canvassing that's been studied by the political scientist Josh Kala and David Brockman. They find that when people do deep canvassing, that they
我们彼此之间是有联系的。我认为凯文的洞察力在于，也许我们并没有在第一时间感受到那种联系的时刻，但在某种程度上，通过这些行动可以让我们进入一种心态，让我们觉得我们有更多的联系。是的，这很有趣。我甚至没想过这一点，你之所以这样做，部分原因可能是为了你自己，你知道，让自己进入好奇、开放、对他人作为一个人感兴趣的正确心态。这让我想起了一点关于政治学家乔什·卡拉（Josh Kala）和大卫·布罗克曼（David Brockman）研究的挨家挨户拉票的“深度拉票”技术的研究。他们发现，当人们进行深度拉票时，他们
wind up having less partisan animosity towards rival partisans themselves afterwards. So there's this kind of depolarizing effect of being a canvasser. You're less likely to view a whole category of people with antipathy because you see, well, they can actually be listened to, connected with, and moved on important issues in my direction sometimes. When we care about a friend or a neighbor or a family member, it can be frustrating and painful to be at odds with them. The same holds true for nations.
最终会对竞争对手本身产生较少的党派敌意。所以作为一名拉票员有一种去极化的效果。你不太可能对一整类人怀有反感，因为你看到，好吧，他们有时实际上是可以被倾听、被联系，并在重要问题上朝着我的方向移动的。当我们关心朋友、邻居或家人时，与他们不和可能会令人沮丧和痛苦。国家也是如此。
When people care deeply about the state of their country, the alienation they feel from people who disagree with them can lead to despair and rage. When we come back, strategies for grappling with those feelings and ideas from Rob Willer and listeners about how to move forward through our disagreements. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
当人们深切关心国家状况时，他们从与自己意见不合的人身上感受到的疏离感会导致绝望和愤怒。回来后，我们将探讨应对这些感受的策略，以及罗伯·威勒和听众关于如何通过分歧向前迈进的想法。你正在收听的是《Hidden Brain》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is your questions answered, our segment in which we bring back past guests of the show to engage with questions and ideas shared by listeners. Today, we're talking with Stanford University sociologist Rob Willer about how to engage with people who disagree with us and even perhaps persuade them of our point of view. Rob, I'd like to talk about the power of role models in helping us to develop good techniques
我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这是你的问题解答，这是我们的一个环节，我们邀请过去的嘉宾回来参与听众分享的问题和想法。今天，我们正在与斯坦福大学社会学家罗伯·威勒讨论如何与不同意我们的人接触，甚至可能说服他们接受我们的观点。罗伯，我想谈谈榜样在帮助我们发展良好技巧方面的力量
for engaging with other people. It feels increasingly rare to have role models who engage with people who have very different views. Did you have any such role models in your own life when you were growing up? Yeah, I did. I did. Growing up, my mother was a really good role model for how to connect with people, with warmth. She directed international programs for students at University of Kansas, University of South Carolina, and every day was interacting with people just from anywhere on the earth. And as even a little kid, I was seeing like, oh, yeah, you can just talk.
与他人接触。拥有与观点截然不同的人接触的榜样似乎越来越罕见。你在成长过程中生活中是否有这样的榜样？是的，我有。成长过程中，我母亲是一个很好的榜样，她展示了如何以温暖的方式与人建立联系。她负责堪萨斯大学和南卡罗来纳大学的国际学生项目，每天都在与来自地球各个角落的人互动。即使作为一个小孩子，我也看到，哦，是的，你可以直接交谈。
People are people. And they tend to put their best foot forward, especially across lines of difference if you reciprocate or lead with that yourself. And that was, you know, just a really rich experience to have as a kid. Then later, when I was training as a union organizer, I was working with Christian Sweeney, who was a more experienced union organizer and was, you know, really teaching me how to do it. And I wasn't as good of a union organizer as he was and is or than most are. But I learned so much about leading with positivity and inclusion and signaling to someone, I already think I'm in a group with you.
人就是人。他们倾向于展现最好的一面，特别是如果你自己也这样做或带头这样做的话，跨越差异的界限。那对我来说，作为一个孩子，是一次非常丰富的经历。后来，当我接受工会组织者培训时，我和克里斯蒂安·斯威尼（Christian Sweeney）一起工作，他是一位更有经验的工会组织者，他真的在教我如何去做。我没有他那么出色，或者说没有大多数人那么出色。但我学到了很多关于以积极和包容的态度引领，并向某人发出信号：我已经认为我和你在同一个群体中了。
I want you in my group. I'm coming to you with warmth and inclusion. And I want to answer your questions and talk to you about why I think this is such a good idea. And that posture is so different from one of debate or competition or judgment. It's much more, much more attractive and winning. You and your colleagues recently published a study where you looked at how elected officials can sometimes serve as role models for bipartisan engagement. Tell me what you did and what you found, Rob. So we got very interested in this project as a result of the Disagree Better initiative that Spencer Cox, the Republican Governor of Utah, spearheaded starting about two years ago when he became the chair of the National Governors Association. He said, I want to do something that would role model civil engagement across lines of political disagreement, something that seems so scarce right now. Without those lines of connection, real respect being shown, we're not going to be able to cooperate where we do agree,
我想让你加入我的团队。我带着温暖和包容向你走来。我想回答你的问题，并和你谈谈为什么我认为这是一个好主意。这种姿态与辩论、竞争或评判的姿态截然不同。它更具吸引力，也更容易赢得人心。你和你的同事最近发表了一项研究，探讨了民选官员如何有时能成为两党合作的榜样。罗布，告诉我们你做了什么，发现了什么。我们对这个项目非常感兴趣，这源于犹他州共和党州长斯宾塞·考克斯（Spencer Cox）在大约两年前担任全国州长协会主席时发起的“更好地分歧”（Disagree Better）倡议。他说，我想做一些能够为跨越政治分歧的公民参与树立榜样的事情，这在当下似乎非常稀缺。如果没有这些联系，没有表现出真正的尊重，我们就无法在我们达成共识的地方进行合作，
and we're not going to be able to tolerate each other when we disagree, but we need to be able to inhabit the same space, the same country, the same Congress, and so on. So he organized pairs of governors to film public service announcements where they broke bread together, talked about, you know, we kind of kid at each other a little bit, some friendly, you know, jabs here and there, and talked then very openly about how they, you know, they agree on a lot of things, they disagree on a lot of really important things, but that they are respectful of one another and willing to engage across these lines of difference. We found this to be really inspiring and maybe even more than that, really unusual in the current climate. We were interested in whether that sort of message can have influence on other people because it's unusual, because it supports basic decorum and civility and respect across lines, and because it involves leaders. You know, like if you're an American Democrat or Republican, you're going to see someone who's a legitimate elite leader of your group in that ad. So we ran a large survey and field experiment testing the effects of these ads and found that they're quite effective. You know, they increased people's receptiveness to having conversations across lines of political difference.
当我们有分歧时，我们也无法容忍彼此，但我们需要能够生活在同一个空间、同一个国家、同一个国会等等。因此，他组织了州长配对，拍摄公共服务公告，他们在视频中一起吃饭，谈论，你知道，我们互相开点小玩笑，偶尔有一些友好的“挖苦”，然后非常坦诚地谈论他们如何，你知道，他们在很多事情上达成共识，在很多非常重要的事情上有分歧，但他们彼此尊重，并愿意跨越这些分歧进行接触。我们发现这真的很鼓舞人心，甚至不仅如此，在当前的气候下，这真的很不寻常。我们很感兴趣这种信息是否能对其他人产生影响，因为它不寻常，因为它支持基本的礼仪、文明和跨界尊重，而且因为它涉及领导者。你知道，如果你是一个美国的民主党人或共和党人，你会在那个广告中看到一个你所在群体的合法精英领导者。因此，我们进行了一项大型调查和实地实验，测试了这些广告的效果，发现它们非常有效。你知道，它们提高了人们跨越政治分歧进行对话的接受度。
They increase everyday Americans intellectual humility. They reduced everyday Americans animosity towards rival partisans. It also increased approval for the governors that took part in the public service announcements. they show increased approval and respect and interest in voting for them, seeing them there. I think when people see that kind of leadership across lines of difference, it's attractive. When it comes to role models, it seems that there may be a special opportunity for people who've embraced one worldview and then moved to another. Here's an email we received on that from listener Emily, who writes, I wonder if we might be able to help bridge divisions by specifically locating for,
它们提高了普通美国人的知识谦逊。它们减少了普通美国人对敌对党派成员的敌意。这也提高了人们对参与公共服务公告的州长的支持率。他们表现出更高的支持、尊重和投票意愿，看到他们出现在那里。我认为当人们看到那种跨越分歧的领导力时，它是很有吸引力的。谈到榜样，对于那些拥抱了一种世界观然后转向另一种世界观的人来说，似乎有一个特殊的机会。这是我们收到的一封来自听众艾米丽（Emily）的电子邮件，她写道，我想知道我们是否可以通过专门寻找，
folks who have changed their political views independently. These folks, of which I am one, have an inherent understanding of the other side's beliefs. They can speak to those beliefs, having held them themselves. They can also speak to what moved them, what influenced them, and why. For myself, I find I hold greater compassion and understanding, having come from one ideology and move to another, than others within my new group. The fact that I can be more understanding of the opposition seems to flummox my current group, but I see my position as a strength rather than a betrayal. What do you make of Emily's comment, Rob? Well, I think Emily is spot on. In fact, systematic social psychological research on exactly
那些独立改变了政治观点的人来帮助弥合分歧。这些人，我也是其中之一，对另一方的信仰有着内在的理解。他们可以谈论这些信仰，因为他们自己也曾持有过。他们也可以谈论是什么触动了他们，什么影响了他们，以及原因。就我个人而言，我发现与新群体中的其他人相比，从一种意识形态转向另一种意识形态后，我拥有更大的同情心和理解力。我能更理解反对派的事实似乎让我的现任群体感到困惑，但我认为我的立场是一种力量，而不是背叛。罗布，你对艾米丽的评论有什么看法？嗯，我认为艾米丽说得非常对。事实上，关于这一现象的系统性社会心理学研究证实了她的直觉，即已知从一种观点转变为另一种观点的人可以更具说服力。在日常生活中，这种情况发生的原因可能有很多。一方面，那个转变者更了解什么是有说服力的诉求，也许是什么样的说服诉求或论证方式改变了他们的想法。他们也有一些原始材料来建立共同的身份联系。我发现，即使我有非常强烈的政治信仰，如果我和一个南方人交流，我们有很多共同点和共同经验可以借鉴，我们可以建立一种关系，然后在此基础上进行政治对话，
this phenomenon confirms her intuition that people who are known to have converted from one view to the other can then be more persuasive. And there's probably a lot of reasons why this is the case in everyday life. On the one hand, that converted person just knows more about what would be a persuasive appeal, maybe what was the persuasive appeal or line of argumentation that changed their mind. They also have some raw material to draw a common identity connection. I find myself, even if I have very strong political beliefs, if I'm engaging with someone from the South, like we've got a lot of common ground and common experience to draw upon and we can build a relationship that we then can have a political conversation on top of
比普通陌生人之间有更多的尊重、同理心、友善和温暖。因此，那种建立联系的原始材料可以被一个有社交技巧的人利用，为建设性的对话打下基础。我想分享我们收到的一条信息，这是一个跨越政治分歧进行建设性接触的良好榜样。这个例子来自听众露西亚（Lucia），它发生在社交媒体上。在这种情况下，当时正值关于批判性种族理论（Critical Race Theory）以及是否应该进入课堂的大辩论。当时流传着很多错误信息，我有点忽视了政治光谱另一边的任何人，认为他们只是不知道那是什么，也不想花时间去
with a greater respect and empathy and kindness and warmth than, you know, the average pair of strangers would. And so that raw material for drawing a connection can be used by, you know, someone who's socially skilled to build that foundation for a constructive dialogue. I'd like to share a message that we received that is a good example of modeling constructive engagement across political divides. This example comes from listener Lucia, and it unfolded on social media. And in this situation, this was around the time that there was this big debate about critical race theory and whether or not to be in classrooms. And there's a lot of misinformation floating around, and I kind of just disregarded anybody who was on the other side of. the political spectrum that they just didn't know what it was and they didn't want to take the time to
理解。嗯，所以在TikTok直播上，我正在和直播中的其他人就批判性种族理论进行辩论。一位男士走了上来，我没有仅仅在事实上和他来回争论，而是停下来问他，好吧，你和我分享一下你认为批判性种族理论是什么，以及你认为学校里正在发生什么。所以当他向我解释他认为它是什么时，我向他解释说，嗯，人们贴上批判性种族理论标签的东西，
understand. Um, and so on a TikTok live, I was, uh, debating back and forth with some other individuals on this live about critical race theory. And one gentleman came up and instead of just going back and forth with him on the facts, I kind of just stopped and asked him like, okay, you share with me what you believe critical race theory is. and what you think is happening in the schools. And so when he explained to me what he thought it was, and then I explained to him, I said, well, the thing that people are labeling as critical race theory
仅仅是，例如，谈论奴隶劳动对美国经济的影响，作为其历史的一部分。你知道，像谈论棉花和糖的出口以及它来自哪里，它来自奴隶劳动的事实，这样简单的事情，他们把这贴上批判性种族理论的标签。他们想让我们把它拿掉，
is simply just, for example, talking about the impacts of slave labor on the U.S. economics as part of its history. You know, something as simple as talking about the export of cotton and sugar and where that's coming from, the fact that it came from slave labor, they're labeling that as critical race theory. And they want us to take that out,
不要教授完整的历史。当我向他解释这一点时，他实际上理解了，并明白他对批判性种族理论的想法是被误导了。所以当我们能够从那一点开始对话，并且我站在他的立场上与他交流时，把他带到我这边实际上容易多了。在对话结束时，他实际上说，是的，批判性种族理论作为大学选修课教授完全有道理。所以，这再次说明，这听起来很简单，但是的，只是站在人们的立场上与他们交流，并从那里开始对话。
and not teach the whole history. And when I explained that to him, he actually understood and understood that his idea of critical race theory was misinformed. And so when we were able to kind of start a conversation from that point, and I met him where he was at, it was actually a lot easier to bring him to my side. And at the end of the conversation, he actually said, yeah, it makes total sense that critical race theory be taught as an elective in college. And so that's, again, it's something that, it sounds so simple, but yeah, just meeting people where they're at and starting a conversation there.
罗布，你对露西亚的故事有什么看法？嗯，我认为露西亚在这里的参与非常明智，你知道，在它变成激烈的争论之前先停一下。让我们建立术语的共同定义，你知道，如果我们要在核心上争论批判性种族理论的价值，让我们确保我们以同样的方式定义它，甚至在使用这个术语时意思相同。否则，整个辩论就毫无意义。我们甚至不知道我们是否真的有分歧，或者我们分歧有多大，或者我们在哪里有分歧。所以这是一个很好的第一步，就像，好吧，为了让我理解，你所说的厌女症是什么意思？或者你所说的生殖权利、清洁能源、种族主义或跨性别权利是什么意思？因为人们经常因为他们所处的环境（可能非常偏颇）而，
What do you make of Lucia's story, Rob? Well, I think Lucia's engagement here is really wise of, you know, stop for a second before it turns into a really intense argument. And let's establish common definitions of terms, you know, like if we're going to be centrally arguing about the worth of critical race theory, let's be sure we're defining it the same way and even meaning the same thing. when we use the term. Otherwise, the whole debate is just pointless. We don't even know if we really disagree or how much we really disagree or where we disagree. So it's a great first step to be like, okay, well, just so I understand, what do you mean by misogyny? Or what do you mean by reproductive rights or clean energy or racism or trans rights? Because it's very often the case that people, because of the information environment they're in, which might be very partisan, they've been
得到关于另一方想法的某些信息，这些信息是非常、非常扭曲或夸大的，或者是基于真实的人，但他们处于那个敌对群体的一种极端边缘。然后当你定义这些术语并澄清时，哦，我不应该仅仅因为我从社交媒体或党派媒体得到的这些表述，就强加关于你的想法和你对术语含义的假设，我实际上需要问你，结果你说的比我假设的要合理得多，也比我所想的要接近得多。我的意思是，这真的可以为一个更好的对话铺平道路，你们从一个距离更近的地方走向彼此。
getting certain kinds of information about what the other side thinks that is very, very distorted or exaggerated or is based on real people, but they're at a sort of, you know, extreme fringe of that rival group. And then when you define these terms and clarify, oh, I shouldn't just import the assumption about what you think and the meaning you have for terms that comes from these representations I'm getting from social media or partisan media, I actually need to ask you, and it turns out what you say is much more reasonable than what I assumed and much closer to what I think. I mean, it can really set the table for a much better conversation where you're coming to each other from, you know, a much shorter distance.
稍后回来，听众将分享更多关于弥合分歧的想法和资源。此外，我们将与罗布·威勒（Rob Willer）讨论被发现能持久减少党派怨恨的技术。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在世界各地的许多国家，人们发现自己处于分裂状态。最近选举中获胜一方的人通常觉得一切都很顺利，他们的领导人很棒。
When we come back, listeners share more ideas and resources for bridging divides with other people. Plus, we talk with Rob Willer about techniques that have been found to create an enduring reduction in partisan rancor. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In many countries around the world, people find themselves divided. The folks who are on the winning side of recent elections often feel everything is going great and that their leaders are wonderful.
失败一方的人不仅觉得正在实施错误的政策。他们觉得他们的国家正在被从他们手中夺走，变成他们不认识的样子。罗布·威勒是斯坦福大学的社会学家。他一直在研究反民主态度以及改变这些观点的各种干预措施。罗布，你最近发表了一项被称为“大型研究”的研究，考察了对民主的态度以及对不同政治观点的人的党派敌意。告诉我关于那项研究以及你的发现。是的。
The people on the losing side don't just feel that misguided policies are being enacted. They feel their country is being taken from them and turned into something they do not recognize. Rob Willer is a sociologist at Stanford University. He's been studying anti-democratic attitudes and various interventions to change these views. Rob, you recently published what's known as a mega study that looked at both attitudes toward democracy as well as partisan animosity toward people of different political views. Tell me about that study and what you found. Yeah.
这项研究始于几年前，当时我们试图寻找有效的干预措施，以减少美国党派成员对敌对党派成员的厌恶或对敌对党派成员的敌意。我们也有兴趣看看我们是否能找到能减少人们对自身阵营领导人反民主行为的容忍度的干预措施。我们发现的结果真的非常非常有趣。因此，在减少美国人党派敌意方面最有效的干预措施是那些建立共同身份联系的干预措施，例如“我们都是美国人”，或者另一种
So this research started a couple years ago when we were trying to find interventions that would be effective for reducing American partisans dislike of rival partisans or their animosity towards rival partisans. And we were also interested in seeing if we could find interventions that would reduce people's tolerance for undemocratic actions by the leaders on their own side. And what we found was really, really interesting. So the interventions that were most effective in reducing Americans' partisan animosity were ones that drew a common identity connection, such as we are all Americans, or another
非常有效的策略是，向人们展示他们不同意的人在接触中实际上是尊重和好奇的生动例子。所以，富有同情心、容易产生共鸣的人，在某种程度上消除了他们对敌对党派成员的刻板印象。然后对于反民主态度，最有效的是另一套策略。其中之一是消除人们对敌对党派成员本身就是反民主行为的忠实粉丝的不准确刻板印象的策略。这里另一个非常有效的策略实际上是斯坦福大学的一名博士生凯蒂·克莱顿（Katie Clayton）和她的导师迈克·汤姆斯（Mike Tombs）提交的一段视频，它强调了民主崩溃在那些不得不应对它的国家看起来有多糟糕，
strategy that was very effective, was one where people were presented with vivid examples of people they disagree with actually being respectful and curious in their engagement. So sympathetic, relatable people that kind of disabuse them of their stereotypes of rival partisans. Then for anti-democratic attitudes, it was a different set of strategies that were most effective. So one was the strategy of disabusing people of their inaccurate stereotypes of rival partisans as themselves big fans of anti-democratic actions. And another strategy that was very effective here was actually a video that was submitted by a PhD student here at Stanford, Katie Clayton and her advisor, Mike Tombs, which highlighted how bad democratic collapse looks in countries that have had to deal with it,
比如俄罗斯、委内瑞拉、土耳其，这些民主倒退加速并进入全面独裁或类似情况的地方，你知道，情况变得非常糟糕。而且，你知道，街头有社会动荡。有暴力的警察镇压。这真的很可怕。然后那段视频以1月6日国会骚乱的镜头作为高潮，仿佛在说，好吧，如果你认为，你知道，美国凭借其世界上最古老的宪法民主制度对这种情况免疫，那么，看看这个。这实际上看起来很像你在其他国家看到的镜头。我认为这让很多人从对民主健康的自满中震惊出来，并让他们思考，哦，哇，我也需要对我的领导人以及
like Russia, Venezuela, Turkey, places where democratic backsliding has accelerated and gone into full-on autocracy or what have you, you know, it gets really bad. And there's, you know, social unrest in the streets. There's violent police repression. It's really scary. And then that video culminated with footage from the January 6th Capitol riot as if to say, well, if you think, you know, America is immune to this with its longest standing constitutional democracy in the world, well, look at this. This actually looks a lot like the footage you're seeing in these other countries. And that, I think, shocked a lot of folks out of complacency around the health of democracy and made them think, oh, wow, I need to enforce these norms on my leaders as well as
敌对领导人执行这些规范。我需要更认真地对待这一点。罗布，我想知道普通人，那些不是政治家或决策者的人，能用这项研究做什么？对于关心民主、关心党派之争和两极分化影响的人来说，个人真的能做些什么来对这个问题产生有意义的影响吗？我的意思是，我认为当你进行跨政治路线的互动时，你可以从中吸取的一个教训是，一定要消除某人对你这一方的人可能持有的刻板印象。比如，确保他们明白，并没有对反民主行为的积极偏好，确保他们不认为存在对政治暴力的积极偏好。再说一次，这适用于左派和右派。你知道，比如如果你是一个民主党人，你正在
rival leaders. I need to take this more seriously. I'm wondering what ordinary people who are not politicians or policymakers can do with the study, Rob, for people who care about democracy and care about the effect of partisanship and polarization, can individuals actually do anything that can make a meaningful impact on the problem? I mean, I think when you're having an interaction across political lines, one lesson you can take from this is be sure to disabuse someone of stereotypes they might have of the folks on your side. Like, make sure they understand there isn't an active preference for undemocratic action, make sure that they don't think there's an active preference for political violence. And again, this goes for the left and the right. You know, like if you're a Democrat and you're
与一个共和党人接触，你知道，消除他们关于民主党人如何爱审查、渴望在道德上评判那些未能达到一套非常具体的道德标准的人的特定刻板印象。这被许多共和党人视为反民主，因为它，你知道，被视为压制自由表达。所以尽可能消除他们的那种观念，你知道，绝对要消除他们认为民主党人喜欢政治暴力的观念。你知道，记住，你知道，许多共和党选民刚刚看到他们的政治候选人，你知道，在上届总统竞选中遭受了两次暗杀企图，其中一次，你知道，离成功只有几英寸远。所以他们也认为
engage with a Republican, you know, disabuse their specific stereotypes about how Democrats are censorious or dying to morally judge people for falling short of a very specific set of moral standards. That is seen as undemocratic by many Republicans because it, you know, it's seen as suppressing free expression. So disabuse them of that notion to the extent you can, you know, and definitely disabuse them of the notion that Democrats, like political violence. You know, remember that, you know, a lot of Republican voters just saw their political candidate, you know, subjected to two attempted assassinations in the last presidential race, one that was, you know, a couple inches from being successful. So they also think
关于政治暴力，并认为这是有意义的，而且来自他们的对手。所以考虑一下，而且，你知道，同样地，如果你是一个共和党人，你知道，你可以告诉民主党人你是如何支持民主的，以及他们投票给唐纳德·特朗普还有其他原因。这些是那种打破刻板印象的互动，可能有效地真正缓和每一方确实存在的对反民主行为的支持。人们有时会觉得，与我们在政治上意见不合的人与我们毫无共同之处。我们今天一直在谈论在政治分歧中建立同理心，我们收到了
about political violence and think that it's meaningful and it's coming from their rivals. So think about, and, you know, and likewise, if you're a Republican, you know, you can tell Democrats about how you're supportive of democracy and that there's other reasons that they've voted for Donald Trump. These are the kinds of stereotype busting interactions that could be effective at actually de-escalating that what support for undemocratic actions does really exist on each side. It can often feel like people who disagree with us politically have nothing in common with us. We've been talking a bit today about creating empathy across political divides, and we got
这条来自听众凯莉（Carrie）的信息。我看了很多未来主义的反乌托邦电影，你知道，当外星人降临并摧毁了地球的大部分地区，或者发生了某种流行病或短缺之类的。它总是以人们试图共同努力而告终，种族、文化和所有这些事情根本不重要。你知道，这基本上是为了生存，试图抚养孩子，过上幸福的生活，并在工作中取得成功，你知道，仅仅是为了生存。所以这就是我与人建立联系的方式，你知道，人类的基本骨架，你知道，仅仅是幸福、生存、照顾你的家人、花时间和他们在一起，以及幽默。
this message from listener, Carrie. I watch a lot of futuristic dystopian-type movies to where, you know, when aliens come down and destroy most of Earths or whatever the case may be or there's some sort of pandemic or a shortage or something. It always ends up with people trying to work together and race and culture and all these things don't matter at all. You know, it's basically survival in trying to raise their kids and have happy lives and success in their employment, you know, just to survive. So that's the way I connect with people is, you know, the bare bones of human beings, you know, just happiness, survival, taking care of your family, spending time with them. and humor.
罗布，你对凯莉的策略有什么看法？关注本质能提醒我们有什么共同点吗？是的，我认为凯莉的分析非常好。我必须承认我有点偏见，因为我也沉迷于这类电影和文学。任何涉及退化，你知道，比如因为某种原因社会崩溃的事情。我就像飞蛾扑火一样。但我认为她说得很对，你知道，美国政治分歧的许多历史分析强调，冷战期间曾经存在这种统一力量，将许多
What do you make of Carrie's strategy, Rob? Can focusing on the essentials remind us of what we have in common? Yeah, I think Kerry's analysis is really good. I have to admit I'm kind of biased because I'm also obsessed with films and literature of this nature. Anything involving the degradation, you know, like the destruction of society for some reason. I'm just like a moth to the flame. But I think he's spot on, you know, and a lot of the historical analysis of political division in the United States highlights that there used to be this unifying force during the Cold War that brought a lot
美国人团结在一起，反对苏联的威胁或类似的东西，或者无论你怎么称呼它。然后在那之前，在第二次世界大战中。所以20世纪中期有一段时期，对许多选民来说在很多方面是统一的。我的意思是，美国有很多缺乏民主参与的情况，这使得投票人口也变得更加人为地同质化。但即使我们只看白人美国选民，二战后的时代，在保卫国家免受外部敌人（无论是感知的还是真实的）侵害方面，确实存在这种统一的体验。我认为我们现在没有那种体验了。更糟糕的是，我们认为像新冠疫情这样的事情可能会达到那种效果，但后来却没有。它们陷入了
of Americans together in opposition to the Soviet menace or what have you, or whatever you want to call it. And then before that, in World War II. And so there was this period in the mid-20th century that was unifying in a lot of ways for a lot of voters. I mean, there's a lot of like lack of democratic access in the U.S. that made the voting population more like kind of artificially homogenous as well. But even if we just look at like white Vodage Americans, the post-World World War II era, there was this experience of unity in defense of the country against outside enemies perceived or real. And I think that we don't have that now. Worse yet, we thought things like COVID maybe were going to amount to that, and then they didn't. And they descended
由于复杂的原因，两极分化甚至更加严重。所以我认为我们可以像凯莉所说的那样，在对话中采用其中一些相同的工具，并引出一些相同的效果。所以一件事是寻找统一我们的共同威胁或公认的问题。比如也许我们都认为通货膨胀是一个问题，或者高物价是一个问题，而这实际上是连接我们的结缔组织，使我们团结起来寻求最佳解决方案。你知道，我们能利用这一点来统一而不是分裂吗？同样，寻找与另一个人的共同点和共同基础，你知道，这已被有力地证明是
into an even worsened polarization for a complex set of reasons. So I think that we can take some of those same tools in conversation in the way Kerry is talking about and draw out some of that same effect. So one thing is finding common threats or commonly recognized problems that unify us. Like maybe we all think inflation is a problem, let's say, or high prices are a problem. and that actually is a connective tissue that brings us together in pursuit of the best possible solutions. You know, can we use that to unify rather than divide? Similarly, finding commonalities and common ground with another person, you know, this has been shown robustly to be as good
和任何事情一样，在减少跨政治和其他分歧的敌意方面同样有效。最后，凯莉的最后一点非常好，即记住你正在交谈的任何人所关心的基本事情，可能就是他们的安全、保障、家庭和社区的经济稳定，为了他们，为了他们所爱的人。这是你们会分享的东西，在那种“我们如何一起照顾我们的基本需求”的层面上建立联系。我认为这可以帮助你建立联系。我想分享最后一个建立跨分歧同理心的想法。它来自我们之前听到的听众艾米丽。她写道，我有一个关于真人秀节目的想法，把持相反意识形态的人聚集在一起，
as anything at reducing animosity across political and other divides. And then finally, Kerry's last point is really good that remembering the fundamental thing, whoever you're talking to is concerned with is probably their safety, security, the economic stability of their household and their community for them, the people they love. And that's something that you're going to share and connecting at that level of like, how do we take care of our basic needs together? That can help you connect, I think. I want to share one last idea for building empathy across division. It comes from listener Emily, whom we heard from earlier. She writes, I had this idea for a reality TV show, bring folks of opposite ideologies together
不告诉他们他们处于光谱的两端，并要求他们共同努力解决一个问题，无论是身体上的还是智力上的，尽管身体上的可能更好。只有在那之后，一旦他们有机会建立关系并欣赏彼此，才会提出政治分歧。然后，可能通过询问每个人问题，他们也许能够发现彼此的人性。你觉得艾米丽的现实怎么样？你觉得艾米丽的现实怎么样？我认为艾米丽应该制作这个节目。我们需要它。这是一个很棒的主意。你知道，它真的让我想起了Civility，这个旨在弥合政治和其他分歧的公民社会组织。他们的方法和她的想法，和艾米丽的想法真的非常相似。他们把
without telling them they are on different ends of the spectrum, and ask them to work together to solve a problem, physical or intellectual, although physical might be better. Only thereafter, once they've had a chance to build a relationship and appreciate one another, would the political differences be raised. Then, possibly by asking questions of each, they might be able to find one another's humanity. What do you think of Emily's reality? What do you think of Emily's reality? I think Emily should produce this show. We need it. It's a great idea. You know, and it really reminds me of civity, this civil society organization that seeks to bridge political and other divides. And their approach is really, really similar to her idea, to Emily's idea. They bring
成对的人带入他们所说的“重触”互动中，他们真的只是想把两个人放在一个房间里，他们需要，你知道，他们想尝试让这些人弥合任何分歧，无论是宗教、种族或民族，显然是政治上的。但他们想在进入政治之前就开始，让我们作为人类开始。他们，你知道，去找A先生说，你知道，斯科特，你为什么不给我们讲讲你的人生故事？然后斯科特，你知道，解释他是谁，他来自哪里。然后是，珍妮，你能不能给我们讲讲你的人生故事？珍妮解释她来自哪里，她是谁，她关心什么。他们有点以此为基础。这持续了15
pairs of people into what they call like heavy touch interactions, where they're really going to just get two people in a room that they need, you know, they want to try to get these folks to bridge whatever divided it's religious, racial or ethnic, political, obviously. But they want to start way before you get into the politics, let's start as human beings. And they, you know, go to person A and say, you know, Scott, why don't you tell us the story of your life? And Scott, you know, explains who he is and where he's coming from. And then be like, Janet, might you tell us the story of your life? Janet explains where she's coming from. who she is, what she's about. And they kind of scaffolded off of that. Like that goes on for 15
分钟，人们分享他们是谁。人们真正是谁通常是听起来相当令人同情和相当容易产生共鸣的事情。所以他们从这种脆弱的立场开始，建立一种信任和承诺，到最后，当他们进入分裂和政治问题时，他们已经有了一些可以建立的东西。而且这两个人通常在短短15分钟的这种引导式互动中，真的可以非常关心彼此。你也可以使用这种相同的通用方法来连接，尽管有政治分歧并可能具有说服力，那就是以故事或叙述的形式分享你自己在某件事上的立场，说明你是如何得出这个立场的。所以也许你对枪支权利持有这种态度的原因是因为你成长的地方，
minutes, people sharing who they are. And who people really are is usually something that's pretty sympathetic to hear and pretty relatable. And so they start from this kind of position of vulnerability and build a kind of trust and commitment where by the end of that, when they get into the divisiveness and the political problems, they've got something to build on. And and these two people often really can care about each other a lot in just 15 minutes with this guided interaction. One way that you can also use this same general approach to connecting despite political difference and potentially being persuasive is to share your own position on something in terms of a story or a narrative of how you came to it. So maybe the reason you have the attitudes that you do on gun rights is because of where you grew up. you know, and the people in your community and what guns were used for and what they were about.
你知道，你社区里的人，枪支是用来做什么的，它们是关于什么的。那是导致你持有这种观点的背景。对于一个不同意你的人来说，这是有用的信息，比如，哦，这不是一个支持暴力的人。这是一个有非常不同的参考群体、经历、影响者等等的人。同样，你也可以使你的立场人性化，你知道，你有点传达了，嘿，我得出这个结论是因为我自己的原因，我自己的经历，你可以对此产生共鸣。你可以看到，如果你站在我的立场上，也许你会有我这样的观点。如果我站在你的立场上，也许我会有你这样的观点，我们受到
And that's the context that led you to have the view you have. That's helpful information for somebody who disagrees with you to know of like, oh, this isn't somebody that's supportive of violence. Like, this is somebody who has a very different reference group, set of experiences, influencers, and all this. Similarly, you can also humanize your position, you know, like you're sort of conveyed like, hey, I came to this, you know, because of my own reasons, my own experiences, and you can relate to that. And you can see where if you were in my shoes, maybe you'd have the views that I do. And if I was in your shoes, maybe I'd have the views that you do, and we're subject to
一些导致我们产生分歧的重大社会力量和经历的影响。但我们已经确定我们在这里是人类，你知道，在这种互动中。如果我们按照艾米丽建议的方式去做。所以我们知道，尽管有这些可以理解的意见分歧，我们还是有很多共同点。现在，我们要如何处理这些分歧？让我们讨论一下。让我们谈谈它。
some major social forces and experiences that are leading us to disagree. But we've established we're human here, you know, in this interaction. if we're doing it the way Emily advises. And so we know we have a lot in common despite these understandable differences of opinion. Now, what are we going to do with those differences? Let's hash it out. Let's talk about it.
罗布·威勒是斯坦福大学的社会学家。罗布，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。这总是一种荣幸和荣誉。谢谢你邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Querell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。
Rob Willer is a sociologist at Stanford University. Rob, thanks so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's always a pleasure and an honor. Thanks for having me on. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury.
塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢我们在《隐藏的大脑》中探讨的想法，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅，Hidden Brain Plus。在那里你会找到你在其他任何地方都听不到的对话。此外，你的订阅有助于资助节目每一集背后的研究、写作和音频制作。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 免费试用 Hidden Brain Plus 七天。如果你使用的是苹果设备，你可以在 apple.com/hiddenbrain 找到我们。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. It's where you'll find conversations you won't hear anywhere else. Plus, your subscription helps to fund the research, writing, and audio production that go into every episode of the show. You can try Hidden Brain Plus with a free seven-day trial by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, you can find us at apple.com slash hidden brain.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。